Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. Returning to W Network and StacTV. The West Side Ripper is back. If you're not killing these people, then who is? That's what I want to know. Starring Kaylee Cuoco and Chris Messina. The only investigating I'm doing these days is who shit their pants.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。回归 W Network 和 StacTV。“西区开膛手”回来了。如果你没有杀这些人，那是谁干的？这正是我想知道的。主演凯莉·库柯和克里斯·梅西纳。我这些天唯一在做的调查是谁拉裤子里了。
Killer messaged you yesterday? This is so dangerous. I got to get out of this. Based on a true story. New season Mondays at 9 Eastern and Pacific. Only on W. Stream on St true story. New season Mondays at 9 Eastern and Pacific. Only on W. Stream on Stack TV. When the conspirators who were lurking in wait for Caligula moved everyone else along, on the grounds that the Emperor wished to be alone, Claudius retreated to a wing of the palace known as the Hermaeum, and not long afterwards,
杀手昨天给你发消息了？这太危险了。我得离开这儿。根据真实事件改编。新季度每周一美东和美西时间晚上 9 点播出。独家登陆 W。在 Stack TV 上观看。当潜伏等待卡利古拉的阴谋分子将其他人支开，理由是皇帝希望独处时，克劳狄退到了宫殿的一个被称为赫尔梅姆的侧翼，不久之后，
alarmed by the distant shouts of, Murder! crept away to a nearby balcony, where he hid himself behind the curtains hanging in front of the door. There he cowered, and as he did so, a soldier who happened to be wandering past noticed his feet and dragged him out intending to ask him who he was, but then as he sank to his knees in terror, recognised him and hailed him as Emperor. The soldier then led him away to where the other Praetorians were all milling around, uncertain what to do. The soldiers put him in a litter, and because his own attendants had run away, took it in turns to carry the unhappy and fearful man on their shoulders to their camp, and all the crowds they passed on the way pitted
被远处“杀人啦！”的喊声惊动，悄悄溜到附近的一个阳台，把自己藏在门前的窗帘后面。他在那里瑟瑟发抖，正当他这么做时，一个恰巧路过的士兵注意到了他的脚，把他拖了出来，本想问他是谁，但随后当他惊恐地跪倒在地时，认出了他并欢呼他为皇帝。士兵随后把他带到其他近卫军四处闲逛、不知所措的地方。士兵们把他放进一乘轿子里，由于他自己的随从都逃跑了，便轮流把这个既不幸又害怕的人抬到他们的营地，沿途他们经过的所有人群都同情
him on the assumption that he was an innocent being bundled off to execution. Received within the ramparts, he spent the night under the protection of the Praetorians, but in a mood of relief rather than of any great expectation. But as the next day passed, so large crowds of people gathered outside the Praetorian camp, agitating for a single man to be given rule and calling for Claudius by name. These chants prompted him to allow an armed assembly of the Praetorians to swear allegiance to him and to promise each one of them 15,000 Sesterces, thereby becoming the first of the Caesars to win the loyalty of the military by paying them a bribe. So that last sentence
他，以为他是一个被捆绑着拉去处决的无辜之人。进入城墙后，他在近卫军的保护下度过了一夜，但心情与其说是有什么巨大的期望，不如说是如释重负。但随着第二天过去，大量的人群聚集在近卫军营地外，煽动将统治权交给某一个人，并高呼克劳狄的名字。这些高呼促使他允许近卫军武装集会向他宣誓效忠，并承诺给每人 15,000 塞斯特斯，从而成为第一位通过行贿赢得军队忠诚的凯萨。所以最后这句话
I'm not sure whether that's really true, but that's Suetonius in his life of Claudius as translated in the New Penguin Classics Edition by our very own Tom Holland. And Tom there, Suetonius, has taken the story forwards from where we left it last time. We left it on a cliffhanger. The Emperor Caligula, mad or not, definitely a populist, has been assassinated by Cassius Caria and the Praetorian Guard and the question is, is Rome going to turn back the clock 60 years to the time of the Republic and all the chaos at the end of the Republic or is it going to continue with the family of Augustus known as the Caesars?
我不确定这是否真的属实，但这是苏维托尼乌斯在他的《克劳狄传》中记载的，由我们自己的汤姆·霍兰翻译的“企鹅经典新版”。汤姆，苏维托尼乌斯在那里将故事从我们上次中断的地方推进了下去。我们把它留在一个悬念上。皇帝卡利古拉，无论疯癫与否，绝对是个民粹主义者，已被卡西乌斯·凯里亚和近卫军暗杀，问题是，罗马是要将时钟拨回 60 年前的共和国时代以及共和国末期的所有混乱，还是继续由奥古斯都的家族——也就是所谓的凯萨家族统治？
So take us forward, what happens next? Yeah, well, it's the pressing question, what happens next? Is an eligible Caesar to hand? Or as you were implying, might it be time to turn the clock back, to go back to the republican system of government? And what makes that question even more pressing is the fact that, as we've been saying throughout this series, the autocracy of the Caesars is not formally a hereditary monarchy. In fact, formally it's not a monarchy at all. And so there are no rules governing the succession. That said, it has come to be accepted that the emperor should be a Caesar. So that means an heir either by adoption, as was the case with Tiberius or by bloodline, as was the case with Caligula of the deified Augustus, the first of the
那么带我们继续，接下来发生了什么？是的，嗯，这是一个迫切的问题，接下来发生了什么？手头有符合条件的凯萨吗？或者正如你所暗示的，也许是时候把时钟拨回去，回到共和制的政府系统了？使这个问题更加迫切的事实是，正如我们在整个系列中一直所说的那样，凯萨们的专制统治在形式上并不是世袭君主制。事实上，从形式上讲，它根本不是君主制。因此，没有任何规则来管话继承。话虽如此，人们已经开始接受皇帝应该是一个凯萨这一观点。这意味着继承人要么通过收养（如提比略那样），要么通过血统（如卡利古拉之于神圣的奥古斯都，第一位
emperors and who is now a god. So the question then is what are the options? Who is there on hand? And I suppose the obvious question, which we didn't touch on in our episode on Circular, is has he left any children? And although he's only 28 when he gets murdered, he hasn't stinted when it comes to having wives. I mean, he's burned through a lot of them. And his last wife is the one that actually seems to have been his great love and she's a woman called Melonia Cisonia. And she isn't particularly young. She's not particularly attractive, but she does seem to have appealed to something very deep and colligula. I mean, he really knows. Well, actually, I think we can have a fairly
皇帝，现在他已经是一位神）。所以问题在于有哪些选择？手头有什么人？我想显而易见的问题是——我们在关于卡利古拉的那期节目中没有触及的——他留下任何孩子了吗？尽管他在被谋杀时只有 28 岁，但在娶妻子方面他并没有吝啬。我的意思是，他换了很多很多妻子。而他的最后一任妻子似乎真的是他的真爱，她是一个名叫梅洛尼亚·西索尼亚的女人。她并不是特别年轻。她也不是特别有吸引力，但她似乎确实吸引了卡利古拉内心非常深处的东西。我的意思是，他真的很清楚。好吧，其实，我觉得我们可以有一个相当
good idea what it is. They both seem to have certainly have had a taste for dressing up. Lucy Worsley. Well, to a degree. So when he goes riding off to see soldiers or whatever, he dresses her up in a military outfit as well. So she clearly enjoys that. But he also gets her to pose nude for friends. So to that extent, she's not like Lucy Worsley, but she's clearly, she's a fun girl. She gels well with Caligula's inimitable madcap sense of humor. I think it would be fair to think she's a zany funster. Right. And she has given him one child, but unfortunately for fans of the Bloodline of Caligula, that child is a daughter and Caligula has named her after his
清晰的想法，那是什么。他们俩似乎肯定都有盛装打扮的爱好。露西·沃斯利。嗯，在某种程度上。所以当他骑马去见士兵或做其他事情时，他也把她打扮成军装。所以她显然很喜欢这个。但他也让她为朋友们摆出裸体姿势。从这个意义上说，她不像露西·沃斯利，但她显然是一个有趣的女孩。她和卡利古拉无可比拟的疯狂幽默感很合拍。我想可以说她是一个古怪的开心果。没错。她为他生了一个孩子，但不幸的是，对于卡利古拉血统的粉丝来说，那个孩子是一个女儿，卡利古拉以他
beloved sister who died and whom he deified in his grief. So he calls her Julia Drusilla. And she's a lovely sweet-natured girl, isn't she by all accounts? Yeah, so this again I think is one of the, I mean very funny bit from Serotonius. So this is Caligula talking about Drusilla. There existed no sure evidence that she was indeed his child, he believed, than her temper, which was so violent whenever she played with other little children she would scratch at their faces and jab at their eyes with her fingers so daddy watches on, oh chip off the old block. So what happens to them? Well according to Suetonius they get murdered along with Caligula. He says that they've been
深爱的、已经去世并在他的悲痛中将其神化的姐姐的名字来为她命名。所以他叫她朱莉娅·德鲁西拉。根据各方面的说法，她是一个可爱、性格甜蜜的女孩，对吧？是的，所以这再次我认为是苏维托尼乌斯非常有趣的一个地方。所以这是卡利古拉在谈论德鲁西拉。他认为没有确凿的证据表明她确实是他的孩子，除了她的脾气，当她与其他小孩子玩耍时，她的脾气是如此暴烈，以至于她会抓他们的脸，用手指戳他们的眼睛，所以爸爸在旁看着，哦，真是虎父无犬女。那么他们怎么样了？好吧，根据苏维托尼乌斯的说法，他们和卡利古拉一起被谋杀。他说他们曾
accompanying him when they run into the Praetorians but Josephus, the great Judean historian who has very precise information about what happens, he reports that they weren't with him, but when the news came that he'd been murdered, they come and seek out the body of their husband straight father, and they find him and they kind of lie prostrated with grief, mourning him. And this is where they are found by a Praetorian who has been sent to dispatch them. And Cezonia looks up at the soldier and she's, you know, sobbing and she says, finish the last act of the drama. So again, this idea that everyone in the house of Caesar is an actor on a stage and the Praetorian duly does as he's told. He slits Cezonia's throat and
陪着他，当时他们遇到了近卫军；但伟大的犹太历史学家约瑟夫斯，他掌握了关于所发生事情非常精确的信息，他报道说他们当时不在他身边，但当他被谋杀的消息传来时，他们出来寻找他们名义上的丈夫和父亲的尸体，他们找到了他，并悲痛欲绝地俯卧着哀悼他。正是在这里，他们被一个被派去处决他们的近卫军找到了。西索尼亚抬头看着士兵，她（你知道的）泣不成声，她说：“完成戏剧的最后一幕吧。”所以同样，凯萨家族中的每个人都是舞台上的演员这一观点，近卫军理所当然地照做了。他割断了西索尼亚的喉咙，
he picks up a little Drusilla and he smashes out her brains on the side of a wall. So that's the end of them. So they have gone and there are no male descendants of Augustus at all, full stop. And there's no male candidate with the blood of Augustus in their veins to succeed Caligula. And so it's not surprising that there are many in the Senate who do think, well, this might be the time to bring back the, the Republic to kind of wake up from this terrible nightmare that we've been living through. And so that evening, you know, the soldiers come, the guards come and they say to the consuls who've taken control of the city now that Caligula is gone and they say, what's the watchword? And they say liberty.
抱起小德鲁西拉，把她的脑袋往墙上一砸。这就是他们的结局。所以他们已经不在了，奥古斯都的男性后代已经一个不剩了，句号。也没有任何流淌着奥古斯都血液的男性候选人来继承卡利古拉。因此，参议院里有许多人认为，这可能是带回共和国、从我们一直经历的这场可怕噩梦中醒来的时机，也就不足为奇了。因此那天晚上（你知道的），士兵们来了，卫兵们来了，他们对控制了这座城市、在卡利古拉死后接管了城市的执政官们说，他们问：“口令是什么？”他们说：“自由。”
So it's all very noble and upstanding. And the next day they have a kind of very grandiose, florid debate on the need to restore the Republic. Words like liberty and various other abstractions are banded around with great abandon. But while they are having this debate, they are forgetting the fact that there are other players in this crisis. One group of which of course is the praetorians, the imperial guard who some of whom had been prompted to murder Caligula, but who absolutely do not want to see the overthrow of the monarchy because they depend on it for their status and their income. So obviously they don't want to
所以这一切都非常高尚和正直。第二天，他们就恢复共和国的必要性进行了一场非常宏大、辞藻华丽的辩论。“自由”以及各种其他抽象概念被肆意抛出。但正当他们进行这场辩论时，他们忘记了一个事实，即这场危机中还有其他参与者。其中之一当然是近卫军——近卫军中的一些人曾促使暗杀卡利古拉，但他们绝对不想看到君主制被推翻，因为他们的地位和收入都依赖于君主制。所以很显然，他们不想要
republic, there'd be no role for them. And the other kind of player in the drama, of course, is the people, the mass of the Roman people, who likewise mourn Caligula. They're very upset that he's gone. And they too want a Caesar, because it is Caesar who keeps them fed above all. It's Caesar who organises the grain supply. And it's Caesar who keeps the masses entertained, who provides the gladiatorial shows and so on. So they likewise don't really want a republic. So let's get back to this moment of the curtain. This bloke in the Palatine, the Praetorian, he sees these feet sticking out under the curtain. He takes Claudius to the Praetorian camp and presumably the Praetorians at this point are thinking of Claudius purely as their
共和国，那将没有他们的容身之地。而戏中的另一种参与者，当然是人民，罗马人民大众，他们同样哀悼卡利古拉。他走了，他们非常难过。他们也想要一个凯萨，因为正是凯萨让他们有饭吃，最重要的是。是凯萨组织了粮食供应。是凯萨让大众保持娱乐，提供角斗士表演等等。所以他们同样并不真正想要一个共和国。让我们回到那个挂着窗帘的时刻。这个帕拉蒂尼山的家伙，这个近卫军，他看到这些脚从窗帘下面伸出来。他把克劳狄带到近卫军营地，想必近卫军此时把克劳狄纯粹看作是他们的
puppet. He's somebody from the family, so they feel a sentimental attachment perhaps and they think we need a figurehead. Here's this bloke, who cares what his backstory is. He's got the right bloodline. Great. Bring him in. Well, we'll discuss in due course, I think, whether it's just luck or whether it's perhaps something slightly more organised. But yes, you're right. They find Claudius. Claudius is a part of the August family. He's quite old by this point. He's born in 10 BC. So, Caligula is murdered in 41. So he's into his fifties. And people may be wondering, well, I mean, if he's in his fifties, he's a member of the August family. Why hasn't he become emperor before? Why isn't he the obvious candidate? And I suppose, you know, why hasn't Caligula killed him?
傀儡。他是这个家族的人，所以他们或许有一种感伤的依恋，他们认为我们需要一个名义上的领袖。就是这个家伙，谁在乎他的背景故事呢。他有正确的血统。太好了。把他带进来。好吧，我想我们稍后会讨论，这究竟只是运气，还是也许稍微更有组织性的一些东西？不过是的，你说的对。他们找到了克劳狄。克劳狄是奥古斯都家族的一员。此时他年纪已经不小了。他出生于公元前 10 年。因此，卡利古拉在 41 年被暗杀。所以他已经五十多岁了。人们可能会想，好吧，我的意思是，如果他五十多岁，又是奥古斯都家族的成员，为什么他以前没有成为皇帝？为什么他不是显而易见的候选人？我想，（你知道的）为什么卡利古拉没有杀他？
If he's an alternative Emperor. And actually, I said he's got the right bloodline, but that's not quite right, isn't it? Because now it comes back to this issue that Suetonius was very interested in with Caligula, which really loomed large for Suetonius then, and I guess must do now again, which is exactly whom are you descended from? Yeah, this really, really matters. So who is Claudius? Um, so to answer that, we need to go back to the scandalous marriage that, uh, Augusta's had with this woman called Livia. So Livia is a Claudian.
如果他是一个替代皇帝的话。事实上，我说他有正确的血统，但这并不完全正确，不是吗？因为现在这又回到了苏维托尼乌斯对卡利古拉非常感兴趣的那个问题，这在当时对苏维托尼乌斯来说确实占据了很大的分量，我想现在也一定如此，那就是你到底是谁的后代？是的，这真的非常非常重要。那么克劳狄是谁？嗯，为了回答这个问题，我们需要回到奥古斯都与一个名叫利维亚的女人之间的那场丑闻般的婚姻。所以利维亚是一个克劳狄家族的人。
She had previously been married to another Claudian. She'd had a baby boy, Tiberius. She's then pregnant by her first husband when Augustus decides he really wants her and marries her. He's in a position to obviously impose his will. So Livia is massively pregnant when she marries Augustus and shortly afterwards she gives birth to a second son who is called Drusus. And Drusus, like Tiberius, is a tremendous war hero. He's entrusted by Augustus with assorted German campaigns. He invades so far east that he reaches the line of the Elbe where he sees the ghostly apparition of a huge woman telling him to turn back. But he's very dashing, very heroic.
她以前曾嫁给另一个克劳狄家族的人。她生了一个男婴，提比略。当奥古斯都决定他真的想要她并娶她时，她正怀着前夫的孩子。他显然处于能够强加自己意愿的地位。所以当利维亚嫁给奥古斯都时，她已经身怀六甲，不久之后她生下了第二个儿子，名叫德鲁西斯。德鲁西斯和提比略一样，是一位了不起的战争英雄。奥古斯都委托他进行各种德国战役。他向东入侵，甚至到达了易北河一线，在那里他看到了一个巨大女人的幽灵幻象，告诉他回去。但他非常潇洒，非常英勇。
And then he dies young, which of course confirms his kind of reputation in the hearts of the Roman people. And it's all kind of very, you know, early years of Rome in a story by Livy. Tiberius escorts the corpse of his brother back to Rome on foot, weeping the whole way, very, very kind of heroic tableau. So Drusus is much admired, much loved. And fortunately, he has given the Roman people another war hero because Drusus is the father of Germanicus, who we talked about in the previous episode, the father of Caligula, very dashing, perfect in every way apart from his spindly legs, absolute war hero again, and everyone loves him. However, Germanicus is not Drusus' only son. So he has a second son, and this is Claudius. And Claudius, as we said, is born in 10 BC, 1st of August, at Lugdunum,
然后他英年早逝，这当然巩固了他在罗马人民心中的声誉。这一切都非常具有李维故事中罗马早年风范。提比略步行护送他兄弟的尸体回罗马，一路痛哭，非常非常具有英雄主义的画面。因此，德鲁西斯备受钦佩，备受喜爱。幸运的是，他为罗马人民带来了另一位战争英雄，因为德鲁西斯是日耳曼尼库斯的父亲——我们在上一集里谈到过他，他是卡利古拉的父亲——他非常潇洒，除了细长的腿外各方面都完美无缺，绝对又是一位战争英雄，人人都爱他。然而，日耳曼尼库斯并不是德鲁西斯的唯一儿子。所以他有第二个儿子，这就是克劳狄。正如我们所说，克劳狄出生于公元前 10 年 8 月 1 日，在卢格杜农，
which is Lyon in Gaul, the kind of the great cult centre for the Augustan cult in Gaul. And Claudius is born, Drusus dies the following year in 9 BC, and so the infant Claudius is raised by his mother, Antonia, who is the daughter of Mark Antony. So just to recap for people who don't know the family tree in front of them, Claudius is the nephew of Tiberius. He is the brother of Germanicus who never got to become emperor. He's also the grandson of Mark Antony. I mean, he's very well connected. Yeah. And he's the step-grandson of Antony's great rival, the first emperor, Augustus. So he has all kinds of connections, although the crucial one, the one with Augustus, is not a blood
也就是高卢的里昂，高卢奥古斯都崇拜的大型邪教中心。克劳狄出生后，德鲁西斯于次年即公元前 9 年去世，因此幼年的克劳狄由他的母亲安东尼娅抚养长大，安东尼娅是马克·安东尼的女儿。所以为了给那些面前没有家谱的人回顾一下，克劳狄是提比略的侄子。他是从未能成为皇帝的日耳曼尼库斯的兄弟。他也是马克·安东尼的孙子。我的意思是，他背景深厚。是的。而且他是安东尼的死敌、第一位皇帝奥古斯都的继孙。所以他有着各种各样的关系，尽管至关重要的一种关系——与奥古斯都的关系——并不是血缘
connection. Yeah, and that wouldn't be an absolutely hopeless problem because Tiberius wasn't, but he gets adopted and in the Roman system, if you get adopted, then you do become the son. I mean, there's no, you know, I mean, as good as being a kind of blood, a blood son. So it would have been possible for Augustus or Tiberius at some point to have adopted Claudius, but they don't. And why do they not? Well, the words of Suetonius, for almost the entire length of his childhood and adolescence, he suffered from a range of chronic illnesses. These left him so impaired both mentally and physically that even once he had come of age, he was regarded
关系。是的，那不会是一个绝对无望的问题，因为提比略也不是，但他被收养了，而在罗马体系中，如果你被收养了，那么你确实成为了儿子。我的意思是，没有（你知道的），我的意思是，和血亲、血亲儿子一样好。因此，奥古斯都或提比略在某个时候是有可能收养克劳狄的，但他们没有。他们为什么不呢？好吧，用苏维托尼乌斯的话说，在他几乎整个童年和青春期，他都患有一系列慢性疾病。这些疾病使他在精神和身体上都受到了极大的损害，以至于即使在他成年之后，他也被认为
as unfitted for either public or private duties. Right. And what are these illnesses? Well, so Suetonius goes on to list them. He has weak knees, which gives him a kind of hobbling, almost kind of limping gait. His laughter, Suetonius says, is an unbecoming bray. It's a bit like Kamala Harris. I was about to say Kamala Harris. People gave her a lot of hard time, but I didn't mind her laugh actually. I thought it was quite endearing. Well, you might have liked Claudius's then.
不适合履行公共或私人职责。没错。这些疾病是什么？好吧，苏维托尼乌斯接着列举了它们。他膝盖虚弱，这使他的步伐有一种蹒跚、几乎是跛行的步态。苏维托尼乌斯说，他的笑声是一种不体面的嘶叫。这有点像卡玛拉·哈里斯。我正想说卡玛拉·哈里斯。人们给她带来了很多困难，但其实我并不介意她的笑声。我觉得它挺讨人喜欢的。好吧，那你可能也会喜欢克劳狄的了。
But I wouldn't say hers was a bray. If his was a bray, I would dislike it because I don't like a braying laugh. Okay. Well, Suetonius says it was a bray. So obviously it was because your Tony is, is never wrong. So Tony says he stammers and twitches. Yeah. And when he gets angry, he drooled and snorted mucus. And I hate that in a man, Tom, that's the snorting of mucus. And apparently Claudius gets angry quite a lot.
但我不会说她那是嘶叫。如果他的那是嘶叫，我会讨厌它，因为我不喜欢嘶叫的笑声。好吧。苏维托尼乌斯说那是嘶叫。所以显然就是那样，因为苏维托尼乌斯是永不犯错的。苏维托尼乌斯说他口吃且抽搐。是的。当他生气时，他会流口水并哼鼻涕。我讨厌男人那样，汤姆，那就是哼鼻涕。显然克劳狄经常生气。
So there's quite a lot of snot flying around the Palatine. Yeah. So clearly he, he suffers from various ailments and disadvantages and people might be wondering, well, do his grandmother, Livia and his mother, Antonia show him sympathy and compassion or are they monstrously ableist? And I'm afraid to say that they are monstrously ableist. So Livia is so mortified by having this grandson who kind of twitches and limps and blows snot everywhere that she can barely bring herself to talk to him and generally communicates with him by kind of sending him written missives. And again to quote
所以帕拉蒂尼山上到处飞舞着鼻涕。是的。所以很显然，他遭受着各种病痛和残疾的折磨，人们可能会想，他的祖母利维亚和母亲安东尼娅对他是报以同情和怜悯，还是对残疾人怀有骇人听闻的偏见？我很遗憾地说，他们对残疾人怀有骇人听闻的偏见。所以利维亚对有这样一个会抽搐、跛行、到处喷鼻涕的孙子感到如此丢脸，以至于她几乎不跟他说一话，通常是通过（你知道的）给他发书面信件来与他交流。还是引用
Suetonius, his mother Antonia used to describe him as a monstrosity of a human being, begun by nature but only half finished, and would accuse anyone whose stupidity she particularly wished to emphasise of being a bigger fool than her son Claudius. But actually I tell you he's really nice to him, and this bears out my view that actually I think you're very hard on this person and you paint him in an unduly dark light, and that is Augustus. Augustus is ultimately a kind man and is lovely to Claudius. Except when slaughtering senators.
苏维托尼乌斯的话，他的母亲安东尼娅过去常常将他描述为人类的畸形，由大自然开头却只完成了一半，并且会将她特别想强调其愚蠢的任何人指责为比她的儿子克劳狄还要更大的笨蛋。但实际上我告诉你，他对他真的很好，这证实了我的观点：其实我认为你对这个人太苛刻了，你把他描绘成一种过分阴暗的光线，那个人就是奥古斯都。奥古斯都归根结底是一个善良的人，对克劳狄很好。除了屠杀参议员的时候。
Yeah, but who cares about them? He's very nice to Claudius, isn't he? He's very nice to Claudius. He's not very nice to Claudius. Yeah, but compared with the rest of the family, Tom. He's nicer than his mother, for sure. I mean mean Augustus agrees that it would be embarrassing to his regime to have Claudius kind of exposed to the public eye, but he does kind of recognise qualities in Claudius. Read Tom to the listeners what Augustus wrote about him.
对，但谁在乎他们呢？他对克劳狄很好，不是吗？他对克劳狄很好。他对克劳狄可没那么好。是的，但与家族里的其他人相比，汤姆。他肯定比他母亲好。我的意思是，奥古斯都同意让克劳狄暴露在公众视野中会对他的政权造成尴尬，但他在某种程度上确实承认了克劳狄身上的品质。汤姆，给听众读读奥古斯都是怎么写他的。
Right, so this is a letter quoted by Suetonius. I mean I love it when Suetonius quotes letters, you feel you know really up close. And yeah Augustus wrote to Livia, the poor boy has Quaterat Demonstrandum. There's another letter where he says, it's amazing, I went to hear Claudius give a talk about some academic subject and it was brilliant. Amazing. Okay, now you said to give a talk about this academic subject. Now it's true, you can be academically very prominent and a complete and utter fool. And I think we can all think of people who tick that particular box. But you, this business that Antonio said, Oh, anyone who's really stupid, I call him a bigger fool than, than Claudius and Claudius is an absolute dribbling idiot. If
好的，所以这是一封被苏维托尼乌斯引用的信。我的意思是，我喜欢苏维托尼乌斯引用信件的时候，你会觉得真的很近距离。是的，奥古斯都写信给利维亚，可怜的男孩有“Q.E.D.（证明完毕）”。还有另一封信，他说，太神奇了，我去听克劳狄就某个学术话题发表演讲，太精彩了。太惊人了。好了，现在你说就这个学术话题发表演讲。现在确实，你可以在学术上非常突出，但却是个彻头彻尾的傻瓜。我想我们都能想到符合特定条件的人。但是你，安东尼娅说的那种事，“哦，任何真正愚蠢的人，我都叫他比克劳狄更大的笨蛋”，而克劳狄是个绝对流口水的白痴。如果
he's a dribbling idiot, how is it he's giving academic lectures? I mean, again, people who've spent time at our great universities may find that question easy to answer, but no doubt you all have your own answer, Tom. I think that it is a kind of general assumption in the Greek and Roman world that if you look like an idiot, you are an idiot. That's, that's the kind of core assumption. They're not very woke at all on such matters, but it's evident that Claudius, despite sending streams of snot everywhere when he gets cross, is very intellectual academically able. So he's fluent in Greek, he's very knowledgeable about literature and precisely because he's
他是个流口水的白痴，他怎么还能去作学术讲座呢？我的意思是，再次强调，在我们的伟大大学里度过时间的人可能会发现这个问题很容易回答，但毫无疑问你们都有自己的答案，汤姆。我认为在希腊和罗马世界中普遍存在着这样一种假设：如果你看起来像个傻瓜，那你就是个傻瓜。那是，那是核心假设。他们在这些事情上一点都不“清醒（woke）”，但很显然，克劳狄尽管在生气时到处喷射鼻涕，但在学术上非常有智力能力。所以他精通希腊语，对文学有很深的了解，正因为他
not allowed to enjoy public life. You know, he's not allowed to go and follow in the footsteps of Germanicus and lead expeditions into Germany. So that gives him the chance to spend, or I guess if you're a Roman aristocrat, waste his time on scholarly pursuits. And the mark, I guess, of how much he wastes his time, of how contemptible a figure he is by the standards of the Roman aristocracy, is actually he becomes a historian. So he's a total loser. Yeah, a slobbering, twitching, socially incompetent historian. Who would have thought it? Thank goodness there are none of those left anymore, Tom. And Dominic, the other possible point of comparison with historians that certainly I know is that
不被允许享受公共生活。（你知道的）他不被允许去追随日耳曼尼库斯的脚步并领导对德国的远征。所以这给了他花时间的机会，或者我想如果你是一个罗马贵族，把时间浪费在学术追求上的机会。而衡量他浪费了多少时间、按照罗马贵族的标准他是一个多么可鄙的人物的一个标志，实际上是他成了一名历史学家。所以他是个十足的失败者。是的，一个流着口水、抽搐、社交无能的历史学家。谁能想到呢？谢天谢地，现在已经没有这种人了，汤姆。多米尼克，与其他历史学家的另一个可能对比点，我当然知道的是，
he writes enormously long books. So his editor says, so here's a commission to write history of the Etruscans. Could you keep it down to two books? And he writes 20 books. And he gets commissioned to write history of Carthage, make it one book, eight books. Sometimes it's good to write an improperly immersive, well textured history. And that takes multiple volumes. What can I say? With chapters on snooker. And do you know, Claudius would have loved all that because he's very, he's, he, he writes a. You know, he's interested in pretty much everything. And he's a historian.
他写了厚得吓人的书。所以他的编辑说，这里有个委托，写一部伊特鲁里亚人的历史。你能把它控制在两本书以内吗？他写了 20 本书。他受托写一部迦太基的历史，弄成一本书吧，八本书。有时候写一部身临其境、纹理丰富的历史是件好事。这需要多卷本。我能说什么呢？其中有关于斯诺克的章节。你知道吗，克劳狄会喜欢所有这些，因为他非常，他，他写了一部。你知道的，他对几乎所有事情都感兴趣。他是一位历史学家。
He's a contemporary historian. He is a contemporary. He writes about things within living memory. Yes he does, which is very foolish of him or brave. And I think this may be one of the reasons why his mother and grandmother think that he's an idiot because he writes a history of Rome from the assassination of Caesar. And so Tony says he was regularly criticized by his mother and grandmother for covering the events that followed the murder of Caesar. And so because he felt unable to write about them frankly
他是一位当代历史学家。他是一位当代人。他写的是活人记忆内的事情。是的，他确实这么做了，这对他来说非常愚蠢或勇敢。我想这可能是他的母亲和祖母认为他是个白痴的原因之一，因为他写了一部从凯撒遇刺开始的罗马史。苏维托尼乌斯说，他经常受到母亲和祖母的批评，因为他涵盖了凯撒遇刺后发生的事件。因此，由于他觉得无法坦率地
or truthfully, skipped to the subsequent period of peace which followed the civil wars. So obviously, the story of how Augustus comes to power, there's a lot of murder, there's a lot of killing, there's a lot of bloodshed. And basically, Livya is saying to him, you know, just don't go there. We have drawn a veil over all of that. And here you are trying to... Yeah, that's mad for Claudius. Just don't do it. That's absolute rank idiocy. I mean, that is rank idiocy from him to rake all that up again. But he does write it. And he actually, you know, he gets to give a public reading. So it's like he gets invited to a, you know, a literature festival or something. And he he starts reading it. Then just, just, just as he started reading this, I'll quote again, quote
或真实地写下这些事情，便跳到了内战之后的随后的和平时期。所以显然，关于奥古斯都如何掌权的故事，有很多谋杀，有很多杀戮，有很多流血事件。基本上，利维亚在对他说（你知道的），“别去碰那个。我们已经为所有这一切拉上了一层面纱。”而你却在这里试图……是的，这对于克劳狄来说太疯狂了。就是别做。这绝对是彻头彻尾的白痴行为。我的意思是，他把这一切重新翻出来，简直是彻头彻尾的白痴。但他确实写了。事实上，（你知道的）他去进行了一次公开朗诵。所以就像他被邀请去参加一个（你知道的）文学节什么的。他开始朗读它。然后就在，就在，就在他开始朗读这个的时候，我再次引述，引述
Sotanias, a great gust of laughter swept the audience when a bench broke under the weight of an enormously fat man. And even after everybody else had calmed down, Claudius found it impossible to put the incident from his mind and would periodically collapse into fits of giggles. Oh my God. So I'll tell you one thing, Theo would never forgive me if I didn't remind everybody that this is actually what happened to our erstwhile producer, Don Johnson, when we went to New Zealand. Remember he sat on that bench and it collapsed? Yes, I do. Yes, outside of the home of a New Zealand farmer who had just been showing us
苏维托尼乌斯的话，“一阵巨大的笑声席卷了观众，因为一张长椅在一个极其肥胖的男人的体重下压断了。”即使在其他人平静下来之后，克劳狄也发现自己无法将这一事件从脑海中抹去，并且会周期性地陷入咯咯的笑声中。天哪。所以我要告诉你们一件事，如果我没有提醒大家这其实就是我们的前制片人唐·约翰逊（Don Johnson）在我们去新西兰时发生的事，西奥（Theo）永远不会原谅我。还记得他坐在那张长椅上结果长椅塌了吗？是的，我记得。是的，在一个新西兰农场主的家外面，他刚刚带我们
around a cave complex with glow worms. And it had been in the family for 150 years. That was literally the best thing that's ever happened to Theo, watching Don break that bench. Anyway, let's move on. So, Claudius leads, you know, he leads this kind of essentially inoffensive life of the scholar, except watching people break benches and he has to be told often about writing on sensitive subjects, but he doesn't get into trouble. There's no kind of risk to him
参观了一个有萤火虫的洞穴综合体。而且它在这个家族已经传了 150 年了。这简直是西奥经历过的最好的事，看着唐把那张长椅坐断。无论如何，我们继续吧。所以，克劳狄过着（你知道的）这种基本上无害的学者生活，除了看别人坐断长椅，而且他经常被告知不要写敏感题材，但他并没有惹上麻烦。他没有承担任何
or anything. But then in 37, Caligula, who is of course Claudius' nephew, and I'm aware for listeners that it is quite complicated keeping all these relations in the head, but Claudius is Caligula's uncle. So Caligula comes to power, and by this stage, Claudius is in his late 40s. And Caligula's succession is both good and bad news for Claudius. So it's good news because Caligula doesn't really respect the Senate. And so he doesn't mind having Claudius enter it. He appoints Claudius to be his co-consul when he comes to power. And so at last, Claudius has become a senator. And in due course later in Caligula's reign, he gets a second consulship. And when Caligula is absent, Claudius presides
风险或什么的。但在公元37年，卡利古拉——当然是克劳狄的侄子，我意识到对于听众来说，把所有这些亲戚关系记在脑子里相当复杂，但克劳狄是卡利古拉的叔叔。所以卡利古拉掌权了，在这个阶段，克劳狄已经快五十岁了。卡利古拉的继位对克劳狄来说既是好消息又是坏消息。所以这是好消息，因为卡利古拉并不太尊重参议院。所以他不介意让克劳狄进入参议院。他任命克劳狄在他掌权时担任他的共同执政官。所以克劳狄终于成了一名参议员。随后在卡利古拉统治的后期，他获得了第二次执政官任期。而当卡利古拉不在时，克劳狄主持
over kind of public entertainments, public games, and so on. Which must be proof that Caligula thinks of his uncle as a harmless fool, because he wouldn't be promoting him in this way as a potential rival, if he thought he was a serious, formidable person. Yes, I think that's right. And I think that Caligula finds it funny to have Claudius in the Senate and also on hand because then he can bully him. So there are lots of stories that again have the kind of the smack of truth that Caligula will invite Claudius to a dinner party. Claudius is quite old.
了（类似于）公共娱乐、公共游戏等等。这一定证明了卡利古拉认为他的叔叔是一个无害的傻瓜，因为如果他认为克劳狄是一个严肃、令人生畏的人，他是不会以这种方式提拔他作为一个潜在的竞争对手的。是的，我想这很对。而且我认为卡利古拉觉得让克劳狄进入参议院并且在手边是一件很有趣的事，因为这样他就可以欺负他了。所以有很多故事同样带有真相的气息，即卡利古拉会邀请克劳狄去参加晚宴。克劳狄年纪挺大了。
He's also very, very fond of a drink. And so he's very prone to kind of falling asleep when he does all the other, either Caligula and the lads will pelt him with olive stones and bread rolls and that kind of flashman style, flashman style. And there's also this great gag, which, which the Tonyist reports that that they people will put slippers on his hands and then abruptly wake him so that he'll wake with a jolt rub his eyes and have find slippers. I actually find that genuinely funny. Is that the kind of jpe you got up to in the dawns? Yeah, I genuinely think that I'd love to see that. Well, so satanist writes and this is my translation very influenced obviously by
而且他也非常非常喜欢喝酒。所以他在其他人都在做其他事时很容易打瞌睡，要么卡利古拉和伙伴们会用橄榄核和面包卷砸他，那种弗拉什曼风格，弗拉什曼风格。还有一个伟大的恶作剧，苏维托尼乌斯报道说，人们会把拖鞋套在他的手上，然后突然叫醒他，好让他猛地惊醒，揉揉眼睛，却发现手上套着拖鞋。我其实觉得这真的很好笑。那是你们在牛津大学导师家中搞的恶作剧吗？是的，我真心觉得我挺想看那一幕的。好吧，所以苏维托尼乌斯写道——这是我的翻译，显然深受
experience of being on the rest of history, Just for the banter was the excuse. Oh dear. Some people who listen to this podcast say there's too much banter, but I think if anything there is not enough. Well, it's not as much as, it's not banter on the level of Caligula's court. I think that's safe to say. There is one moment where Claudius might be in serious danger, which is people may remember that there's been this conspiracy against Caligula. He's gone to Germany, he's gone to Gaul, he's coming back to Rome and he serious danger, which is people may remember that there's been this conspiracy against Caligula. He's gone to Germany, he's gone to Gaul, he's coming back to Rome and he tells the Senate, I hate you. And the person he says this to is a delegation of senators led
参加《历史的余烬》经历的影响——“纯粹为了开玩笑”是借口。天哪。一些听众说这个播客里玩笑开得太多了，但我觉得如果说有什么不对的话，那就是还不够。好吧，这不像，这不是卡利古拉宫廷水平的玩笑。我想这样说是安全的。有一个时刻克劳狄可能处于极度危险之中，那就是人们可能还记得，针对卡利古拉有这样一个阴谋。他去了德国，去了高卢，他正返回罗马，他处于极度危险之中，那就是人们可能还记得，针对卡利古拉有这样一个阴谋。他去了德国，去了高卢，他正返回罗马，他告诉参议院：“我恨你们。”他对之说这话的人是一个由
by Claudius. And Caligula is furious that Claudius has come. And he basically says, you know, you think that you're playing the role of a tutor disciplining me, like I'm a kind of naughty boy or something. And so Caligula's response to this, it is said is to pick Claudius up and throw him into the, into the Rhone. So the meeting takes place in Lyon, fully clothed. So that's not looking good for Claudius. And there are also, it is said, kind of portents that seem to prophesy the golden future that Claudius can look forward to. So that very first time when he becomes consul and he walks out into the forum and he has all his, you know, his, uh, his lictors with the, the kind
克劳狄领导的参议员代表团。卡利古拉对克劳狄的到来大发雷霆。他基本上是说（你知道的），“你以为你在扮演一个导师来管教我，就像我是一个淘气的小男孩什么的。”所以据说卡利古拉对此的反应是把克劳狄抱起来，扔进——扔进罗讷河里。所以会面发生在里昂，当时克劳狄穿着全套衣服。所以这对外表看来对克劳狄很不妙。据传说，还有一些预兆似乎预示着克劳狄可以期待的黄金未来。就是在他第一次成为执政官、走进广场的那一瞬间，他所有的（你知道的）执官带着那些
of the rods and axes on their shoulders, the markers of Claudius' status, it is said that an eagle descends and lands on their shoulders, the markers of Claudius' status. It is said that an eagle descends and lands on his shoulder. It is said that. That's doing a lot of work. But the fact this story is told... Is worrying for Claudius. Is worrying for Claudius. Yeah.
扛在肩上的带有斧棒的仪仗——克劳狄地位的标志，据说有一只鹰降落并停在了他的肩膀上，克劳狄地位的标志。据说有一只鹰降落并停在他的肩膀上。据说。这发挥了很大作用。但这个故事流传下来这件事……对克劳狄来说是令人担忧的。对克劳狄来说是令人担忧的。是的。
Yeah. Because Caligula want to get rid of him. So is it possible that Claudius could become emperor? I mean, you know, the big problem is he's not descended from Augustus and everyone thinks he's an idiot, but it's still a risk if people are even contemplating the possibility that he might be, you know, capable of becoming the emperor that Caligula will then have him killed because the evidence suggests that's what happens to people who are in the line of descent. In the event of course, Caligula is murdered. The Praetorian finds him hiding behind a curtain. They take him to the camp and Claudius becomes emperor. And the whole way through this, you know, this two day sequence of events, Claudius
是的。因为卡利古拉想摆脱他。那么克劳狄有可能成为皇帝吗？我的意思是，（你知道的）最大的问题是他不是奥古斯都的后代，每个人都认为他是个傻瓜，但如果人们甚至在考虑他可能（你知道的）有能力成为皇帝的可能性，这仍然是一个风险，那么卡利古拉就会派人杀了他，因为证据表明这就是那些处于血统线上的人的下场。当然，在那种情况下，卡利古拉被暗杀。近卫军发现他躲在窗帘后面。他们把他带到营地，克劳狄成为了皇帝。整个过程中，（你知道的）这为期两天的事件序列，克劳狄
is saying, I don't want to be emperor. It's mad. I'm wholly unsuited to it. People will remember that passage that you read. Suetonius ends by saying, he is the first of the Caesars to win the loyalty of the military by paying them a bribe. Now that's not true. I mean, Augustus, Tiberius, and Legla, they'd all recognized what their security depended on. But with Claudius, it's very, very overt. The amount of money he gives is obscene and it's paid when he's in their camp and it enables him to become emperor. So is it possible the stuff about the curtain is nonsense and an invention, a folktale, too good to be true and that actually he's in the conspiracy from the beginning, he's been paying these blokes and actually all this, he may not be acting out of ambition
一直在说：“我不想当皇帝。这太疯狂了。我完全不适合它。”人们会记得你读过的那段话。苏维托尼乌斯以这句话结尾：他是第一位通过给军队行贿来赢得军队忠诚的凯萨。现在那不是真的。我的意思是，奥古斯都、提比略和卡利古拉，他们都认识到他们的安全取决于什么。但对克劳狄来说，这是非常非常公开的。他给的钱数是极其下流的，而且是在他身处他们的营地时支付的，这使他能够成为皇帝。那么，关于窗帘的那些事有没有可能是无稽之谈和捏造，是一个好得令人难以置信的民间故事，而实际上他从一开始就参与了这场阴谋，他一直在付钱给这些家伙，而且实际上所有这一切，他可能不是出于野心
so much as fear. He thinks I'm next for the chopping block, basically I've got to act now, I'm not such an idiot, I've got to act now. I'm not such an idiot. I'm going to act now because otherwise Caligula is going to have me killed. I mean, we'll never know because we don't have the sources. But I think when you weigh them up, I think you'd have to say that's very, very probable. Right. Because otherwise, I mean, the sequence of events has the faint kind of quality of a, you know, a kind of myth or something. Yeah. Exactly. They find him behind a curtain.
而是出于恐惧。他想：“我是下一个要上断头台的，基本上我必须现在就行动，我没那么傻，我必须现在就行动。”我没那么傻。我要马上行动，否则卡利古拉会派人杀了我。我的意思是，我们永远不会知道，因为我们没有史料。但我想当你权衡它们时，我想你不得不说这是非常非常可能的。没错。因为否则的话，（你知道的）事件的先后顺序就带有一种（你知道的）某种神话或类似事物的微弱品质。是的。完全正确。他们发现他躲在窗帘后面。
Find him behind a curtain. Yeah. You know, they, they, they know to find him. They know to take him to the camp and Claudius knows, you know, he's got the money ready to pay the cash. Yeah. He's got the cash ready to pay them. Yeah.
发现他躲在窗帘后面。是的。（你知道的）他们，他们，他们知道去哪里找他。他们知道把他带到营地，而克劳狄知道（你知道的）他准备好了付现金的钱。是的。他准备好了付现金给他们。是的。
So I think it's pretty likely that, that he was involved. And of course, you know, the fact that he's come to power in that way, protesting that he doesn't want to be a part of it, disguises the fact that what has happened is basically a coup. You know, it is a coup, plain and simple. It's the first coup really since Augustus came to power. There's not been a kind of peaceful handover of power. And the consequences of that, the consequence
所以我认为他参与其中的可能性相当大。当然，（你知道的）他以那种方式掌权、坚称自己不想参与其中的事实，掩盖了这样一个事实，即所发生的事情基本上是一场政变。（你知道的）这是一场政变，简单明了。这真的是自奥古斯都掌权以来的第一场政变。权力并没有实现某种和平移交。而这带来的后果，他如何掌权的结果
of how he comes to power and the fact that he's neither a blood nor an adoptive descendant of Augustus, will crucially shape the course of his rule and its character. So Augustus, Tiberius, Caligula, they had ruled as a princeps, as a first man, as a first citizen, even Caligula who had despised the notion that Rome might have any Republican traditions. Nevertheless, I mean, that was officially the role that he was playing. But the thing is that what Caligula had kind of drawn attention to, the brute underpinnings of the imperial system, the fact that it's dependent on military power. There's another aspect to it, which is that if that's the case, if it is a monarchy, a military monarchy, then it's becoming an institution. It's something
以及他既不是奥古斯都的血脉也不是其养嗣后的事实，将至关重要地塑造他统治的进程及其性质。所以奥古斯都、提比略、卡利古拉，他们一直作为元首（princeps）、作为第一人、作为第一公民在统治，甚至连卡利古拉——他曾鄙视罗马可能拥有任何共和传统这种想法。尽管如此，我的意思是，那确实是他当时在扮演的官方角色。但问题是，卡利古拉在某种程度上提请人们注意的是帝国体系的粗暴基石，即它依赖于军事力量。这里还有另一个方面，那就是如果是这样的话，如果它是一个君主制、一个军事君主制，那么它正在成为一种制度。它是某种
that you can inherit, not just the title, but an entire way of administering and governing the empire. And it's Claudius because he doesn't have this family link, because when he gets the name of Caesar, it has to be voted to him by the Senate. It's not his by right. What that does is to reveal to people that this is now something that you can inherit in the form of an institution. And Claudius's ability to make that work, to make the imperial institution, the imperial office work as an institution will be absolutely fundamental to the question of whether he will be a success and ultimately whether the autocracy will be a success and ultimately whether, you know, whether the autocracy will be a success and whether Rome itself will endure and prosper. Right. So high stakes. High stakes. So come back
你可以继承的东西，不仅仅是头衔，还有一整套管理和统治帝国的行政方式。正是克劳狄——因为他没有这种家族联系，因为当他获得凯萨这个名字时，必须由参议院投票授予他，这不是他理所应当的。这样做向人们揭示了，这现在是一项你可以以制度形式继承的东西。而克劳狄让这一切行之有效的潜力，使帝国制度、帝国办公室作为一个制度发挥作用的能力，将绝对是决定他是否会成功、归根结底专制统治是否会成功、归根结底（你知道的）专制统治是否会成功以及罗马本身是否能持久繁荣的核心问题。没错。赌注很大。赌注很大。所以请在
after the break to see if the stammering, twitching, socially inept historian turns out to be a good emperor. This episode is brought to you by NordVPN. Dominic, what do you find useful about NordVPN? Well, Tom, as you know, I am absolutely passionate about NordVPN. One of the things I love about them is their Threat Protection Pro, an absolutely brilliant antivirus tool. It is so effective and so powerful. It is integrated directly into the NordVPN app. So what it does is it protects you from phishing and other cyber threats.
休息后回来，看看这个口吃、抽搐、社交无能的历史学家是否会成为一个好皇帝。本集由 NordVPN 赞助播出。多米尼克，你觉得 NordVPN 有什么用处？好吧，汤姆，如你所知，我对 NordVPN 充满了热情。我非常喜欢他们的一点是他们的“威胁防护 Pro（Threat Protection Pro）”，一个绝对出色的杀毒工具。它如此有效且强大。它直接集成到了 NordVPN 应用程序中。所以它的作用是保护你免受网络钓鱼和其他网络威胁的侵害。
And the brilliant thing about it is it allows you to browse safely and smoothly. And Dominic, I know you're all about cyber security, so you know better than anyone, it can often be very hard to distinguish fake websites from real ones. But the great news is that Threat Protection Pro will prevent you from accessing them. And you know what? NordVPN is actually the first and only VPN app to receive the certification that their anti-phishing software is reliable. That's one of the things that make me so passionate about NordVPN. So to stay secure online, you really should take advantage of our exclusive NordVPN discount. You really should, you know. All you need to do is to go to NordVPN.com slash rest is
最棒的是，它能让你安全、顺畅地浏览网页。多米尼克，我知道你非常关注网络安全，所以你比任何人都清楚，虚假网站往往很难与真实网站区分开来。但好消息是，“威胁防护 Pro”（Threat Protection Pro）能阻止你访问这些网站。你知道吗？NordVPN 实际上是第一款也是唯一一款防钓鱼软件获得可靠性认证的 VPN 应用。这也是我对 NordVPN 充满热情的原因之一。因此，为了保持在线安全，你真的应该利用我们专属的 NordVPN 折扣。你真的应该去看看。你只需要访问 NordVPN.com 斜杠 rest is
history. When you sign up, you can receive a bonus four months on top of your plan. And there is no risk with Nord's 30 day money back guarantee. The link is also in the episode description box. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Claudius, written off for half a century, an idiot, a fool, a stammerer, unfit to be exhibited in public, is now the master of the Roman world. And Tom, how does he do? The answer is actually he does all right, doesn't he? Yeah, he does. He's very proactive. He's full of ideas. He's willing to experiment. And I think you get the sense of a man who has profited from his study of history and
history。注册时，你可以在你的套餐基础上额外获得四个月的奖励。而且 Nord 提供 30 天退款保证，没有任何风险。链接也在本集简介中。欢迎回到《历史的剩余部分》（The Rest Is History）。克劳狄乌斯，被世人否定了半个世纪之久——一个白痴、一个傻瓜、一个结巴，不配在公众面前露面——现在却成了罗马世界的主人。汤姆，他干得怎么样？答案其实是他干得还不错，不是吗？是的，他干得不错。他非常积极主动。他点子很多。他乐于尝试。我想你会感觉到，这是一个从对历史的研究中获益匪浅的人，
from his ringside view of the court of the Caesars. I think he's been sitting there and thinking, well, you know, this is what I do. This is what I try. And he puts these various plans into action. And I think he's a pretty good emperor. And because he's grown up in the court of Augustus and because he studied the reign of Augustus in the context of what had gone before, the kind of the Republican traditions, I think he is alert to a degree that his predecessors kind of hadn't really thought through just
从他作为凯撒宫廷旁观者的视角来看，也是如此。我想他一直坐在那里心想，好吧，你知道，这就是我要做的。这就是我要尝试的。他把这些各种各样的计划付诸实践。我认为他是一个相当不错的皇帝。而且因为他在奥古斯都的宫廷中长大，并且因为他在研究奥古斯都统治时期的同时，也结合了之前的情况，也就是所谓的共和传统，我认为他具备一种前瞻性，而他的前辈们并没有真正想透
how cleverly Augustus had fused these kind of rival traditions that we've been talking about. The kind of the elite traditionalist approach and the kind of populist approach. And Augustus had been brilliant at playing to both galleries, wearing kind of both masks. He had attempted to appeal to the Senate as Tiberius had done and to the people as Caligula had done. Claudius, his aim is to try and repeat that trick to try and get both the Senate and the people on board. Now in doing that, he faces an obvious problem, which is that he lacks the prestige of Augustus. He doesn't have the background. He doesn't have the range of achievements. And of course everyone thinks
奥古斯都巧妙地将我们一直在讨论的这两种相互竞争的传统融合在了一起。一种是精英传统主义的方法，另一种是平民主义的方法。奥古斯都非常擅长迎合这两类人群，戴着两副面具。他曾试图像提比略那样吸引元老院，又像卡利古拉那样吸引人民。克劳狄乌斯的目标就是试图重复这个把戏，试图把元老院和人民都争取过来。现在，在做到这一点的过程中，他面临着一个显而易见的问题，那就是他缺乏奥古斯都的威望。他没有这种背景。他没有那么多的成就。当然，每个人都认为
he's an idiot, which is a kind of ongoing challenge. And on top of that, there's also the fact that there are lots of senators who just really resent him being emperor, partly because lots of them had wanted to restore the Republic and partly also because there were lots in the Senate who think that they could be a much better emperor than this guy who kind of dribbles and shakes and you know, blows snot. And so behind his back, they're constantly mocking him and Claudius is well aware of this. but of course, you know, Claudius is, has been mocked all his life and here he is. He's emperor.
他是个白痴，这是一个持续存在的挑战。除此之外，还有一个事实，那就是有很多元老非常愤恨他当上皇帝，部分原因在于他们中有许多人曾想恢复共和国，部分原因也在于元老院里有很多人认为，他们本可以成为比这个流口水、浑身发抖还流鼻涕的家伙更好的皇帝。因此，在背后他们不断嘲笑他，克劳狄乌斯对此心知肚明。但当然，你知道，克劳狄乌斯一生都在被人嘲笑，而现在他坐在这里。他是皇帝。
And there are plenty of examples of politicians who laughed at a lot of the time, but actually are big enough to ignore it and end up being pretty successful. So Claudius is, I mean, you know, he rules for almost 14 years. And despite the fact that there are kind of repeated displays of resentment and contempt from the Senate, and in fact, even as we'll see the occasional conspiracy, he shrugs it all aside. Now it's true that he is a kind of a he's a bit paranoid. So he's the first emperor to institute friskings of people who were brought into his private presence. And when he first enters the Senate House, it's a month after he's come to power, he does so accompanied by guards. And that's
而且有很多政治家的例子，他们经常被嘲笑，但实际上他们心胸宽广，选择无视这些嘲笑，最终取得了相当大的成功。所以克劳狄乌斯，我的意思是，你知道，他统治了将近 14 年。尽管元老院一再表现出怨恨和轻蔑，事实上，正如我们将会看到的，甚至偶尔还会有阴谋，但他都对此耸耸肩，付之一笑。现在，承认他确实有点偏执是事实。所以他是第一个对被带到他私人面前的人进行搜身的皇帝。当他第一次走进元老院时，也就是他掌权一个月后，他是伴随着卫兵一同前往的。这
a reminder of the fact that, just as Caligula had done, he's identified what the real source of his power within the capital is. And he is unembarrassed about this. So he mints various coins that kind of flatter the Praetorians. So there's one that's stamped with an image of their camp. There's another that shows Claudius shaking hands with the Praetorian standard bearer. Of course, he's given them massive donatives. He also gives massive donatives and pay rises to the legions. And you know, senators can laugh at him all they like, but it's Claudia Susan charge of the legions.
提醒了人们一个事实：正如卡利古拉所做的那样，他已经认清了他在首都权力的真正来源是什么。对此他毫不掩饰。因此他铸造了各种阿谀奉承近卫军的硬币。其中一枚上面印着他们军营的形象；另一枚则显示克劳狄乌斯与近卫军旗手握手。当然，他给了他们巨额赏金。他还给军团发放了巨额赏金和加薪。你知道的，元老院可以尽情嘲笑他，但掌管军团的人是克劳狄乌斯。
So ultimately that is the bedrock of his rule. And I think it's fair to say that even though they may feel resentful, even though they may kind of despise him, obviously he's not calligular. And so it is very hard for any senator not to feel a certain measure of relief that they've got someone who isn't going to try and get off with their wives or, you know, all the other things that he was getting up to. And Claudius, of course, is, you know, he's a historian, so he understands the role the Senate has played in Roman history. He respects it. He basically kind of shares their values. He's an aristocrat, you know, and more than that, he's a Claudian. And so he knows the rules. He knows how to dress. He knows how to speak. he knows how to act the part of a traditional Republican Roman aristocrat.
所以归根结底，这才是他统治的基石。我认为公平地说，尽管他们可能会感到怨恨，尽管他们可能会某种程度上鄙视他，但很显然他不是卡利古拉。因此，任何元老都很难不感到某种程度的宽慰——因为他们迎来的不是一个试图染指他们妻子的家伙，或者你知道的，不是他以前搞出来的那些乱七八糟的事情。克劳狄乌斯当然，你知道，他是一位历史学家，所以他理解元老院在罗马历史中所扮演的角色。他尊重元老院。他基本上认同他们的价值观。他是个贵族，你知道的，不仅如此，他还是克劳狄乌斯家族的人。所以他懂规矩。他知道该怎么穿衣。他知道该怎么说话。他知道如何扮演一个传统的共和派罗马贵族的角色。
And we've talked the whole way through how being a successful emperor really is as much as anything about working out what role you're going to play and then playing it well. Ronald Reagan. Yeah. Being an actor. Yeah. It's a really important thing for any politician and any point in history, I would say. Massively important. Yeah. And if you lack the charisma and the
我们一直在讨论的是，作为一个成功的皇帝，很大程度上其实就是弄清楚你要扮演什么角色，然后把它演好。罗纳德·里根。是的。当演员。是的。对于任何政治家和历史上的任何时期来说，这都是一件非常重要的事情，我想说。极其重要。是的。如果你缺乏魅力和
self-confidence to play a part that will be appealing to people who it's important to influence, then you're not going to be basically a good politician. And on that level, Claudius is a good politician. Now, of course, he has this limp, he has his infirmities, but when he sits down, or when he just kind of stands still, he looks impressive. And Suetonius clearly recognizes that this is important. So he says, especially while lying down, he did not fail to give an impression of majesty and dignity. You know, he looks good. He looks impressive. Now, probably the most single most famous famous thing that he does that people who've
自信去扮演一个能够吸引那些需要施加影响的人的角色，那么你基本上就成不了一个好政治家。从这个层面上讲，克劳狄乌斯是个好政治家。当然，他有跛足，他有身体上的缺陷，但当他坐下来，或者当他只是静静地站着时，他看起来气宇轩昂。苏埃托尼乌斯显然意识到了这一点非常重要。所以他说，尤其是躺着的时候，他不失威严与尊严的印象。你知道的，他看起来很好。他看起来气宇轩昂。现在，也许他做的最著名的一件事——听过很多《历史的剩余部分》的听众都会记得——就是他下令入侵英国。他不是亲自带兵，因为他显然不是那种传统意义上的军人，但他，你知道，他参与其中，他与之联系在一起。对的。这是他的入侵。据推测他这么做是因为他从历史研究中得知，没有什么比一场军事胜利更能激起民众的情绪了，
listened to a lot of the rest of his history will remember is he orders the invasion of Britain. He doesn't personally lead it because he's hardly a kind of obvious military man, but he, you know, he associates, he's associated with it. Right. And it's his invasion. And presumably he's doing that because he knows from his study of history that nothing is better calculated to stir the emotions of the populace than a military
即使这场胜利是针对像英国人这样无能的民族。正是如此。不仅如此，这也是一个克劳狄乌斯和一个凯撒——也就是朱利叶斯家族，这两个在奥古斯都家族中联合起来的伟大家族——他们的祖先所做的事情。他们走出去征服人民。这是尤利乌斯·凯撒做过的事。这是各种克劳狄乌斯家族的将领们做过的事。所以克劳狄乌斯在说，我是他们的继承人。同样，正如你所说，他并没有亲自带兵，但是一旦英国的，你知道的，桥头堡建立起来了，科尔切斯特即将沦陷时，
victory even if it's against a people as useless as the Britons. Exactly. And more than that, that this is what a Claudian and a Caesar, so these, you know, the Julians, that these two great kind of families who've been conjoined in the house of Augustus, that that's what their ancestors did. They went out and they conquered people. It's what Julius Caesar had done. It's what various Claudian generals had done. And so Claudius is saying, I am their heir. And again, as you say, he doesn't actually lead it himself, but once Britain has, you know, the bridgehead has been established and Colchester is on the
克劳狄乌斯亲自前往，他带着大象一同前往，以造成尽可能大的轰动。然后当他回来时，他重现了这一场景。因此，他在战神广场主持了各种情景再演，展示了英国战役的精彩片段：攻占文化名城，各种英国国王投降。在地中海各地，他把自己描绘成一个类似粗暴强奸犯的形象。因此，在现在土耳其境内的阿弗罗蒂西亚斯有一幅浮雕，它将不列颠描绘成一个衣服被撕裂的女人，而克劳狄乌斯则是一个肌肉发达、将她按倒在地的强壮男子。很显然，今天的政治家不会希望自己被这样描绘，但这在罗马观众中很吃香，而且显然这也是克劳狄乌斯希望被看到的形象。
verge of falling, Claudius goes over and he does it with elephants to create as big a splash as possible. And then when he comes back, he reenacts it. So he presides over kind of various reenactments on the campus marshes, showing highlights from the campaign in Britain, cultures are being stormed, various British kings surrendering. And across the Mediterranean, he has himself portrayed as a kind of buff rapist. So there's this freeze from Aphrodisias in what's now Turkey, which shows Britannia as a woman whose robes have been torn from her and Claudius as this kind of muscle-bound guy who's forcing her to the ground. And obviously that's not how a politician today would want to be represented, but that's how you know, plays well with Roman audiences. And it's clearly how Claudius wanted to be seen.
他，你知道的，不再是那个年老、结巴、抽搐的历史学家了。他是一个征服省份、征服女人的行动派。他是一个凯撒。是的。但这不仅限于军事，他喜欢宏大的公共工程，比如大量的液压工程。我认为这样说很公平。所以他非常热衷于水文工程。这是他写过书的另一个领域，他曾写过一本关于美索不达米亚运河的书。
He's, you know, he's no longer the kind of elderly, stammering, twitching historian. He's a man of action who subdues provinces, subdues women. And he's a Caesar. Yeah. But it's not just military, is that he likes a grand plongéeée public works, sort of a lot of hydraulic action. I think it's fair to say. So he's very into hydrology. Another thing he'd written a book about, he'd written a book about canals in Mesopotamia.
天哪，听起来真迷人。是的，除了，你知道的，宏大的公共工程，凯撒热衷于此，奥古斯都热衷于此，克劳狄乌斯也绝对热衷于此。因此，他最著名的祖先之一，阿皮乌斯·克劳狄乌斯，修建了亚比亚大道，这条连接罗马和意大利山丘的伟大道路。克劳狄乌斯似乎对承担改善罗马基础设施这一使命抱有真正的热情。因此，每个皇帝都必须担心的显而易见的事情就是粮食供应。历史上一直存在的问题是罗马没有深水港。所以在台伯河口，这里是奥斯蒂亚港，我知道，多米尼克，
God, sounds fascinating. Yeah, except, you know, Grand Plongée, again, I mean, Caesar had been into that, Augustus had been into that, and the Claudians definitely had been into that. So one of his most famous ancestors, Appius Claudius, had built the Appian Way, the great road that joins Rome to the kind of the hill of Italy. And Claudius seems to be genuinely enthusiastic about taking up that battle of improving infrastructure in Rome. So the obvious thing that every emperor has to worry about is the grain supply. And historically it's been a problem that Rome does not have a deep sea port. So at the mouth of the type of this is port Ostia, which I know Dominic,
你是它的超级粉丝。太棒了。是的。你太爱它了。不是吗？我认为奥斯蒂亚是你所能去的地方中最好的地方之一。如果你去罗马，我对听众唯一的建议就是去奥斯蒂亚安提卡。它和庞贝一样好，而且那里没有其他人。
you're a big fan of you. Brilliant. Yeah. You love it. Don't you? I think Ostia is one of the best places you can go. If you go to Rome, my single recommendation to the listeners is to go to Ostia Antica. It's as good as Pompeii and there's nobody else there.
给你。奥斯蒂亚安提卡。它和庞贝一样好，而且那里没有其他人。给你。你听到了。好吧，克劳狄乌斯听到这个一定会欣喜若狂，因为，因为他，他决定他要，他要在台伯河口修建一个巨大的深水港，呃，当他召集工程师并告诉他们这就是他要做的事情时，他们惊恐地举起双手，说，你知道，千万不要试图这样做，这将是一场灾难。这将是一场类似英国高铁 2 号（HS2）的惨败。但你知道，克劳狄乌斯是凯撒，他
There you go. Youste Antica. It's as good as Pompeii and there's nobody else there. That there you go. You've heard it. Okay. Well, Claudius would be thrilled to hear that because, because he, he decides that he's going to, he's going to build a massive deep sea port at the mouth of the Tiber, um, and when he summons engineers and tells them this is what he's going to do, they throw up their hands in horror and, and say, you know, on no account attempt, this it'll be a disaster. It'll be a kind of HS2 fiasco. But you know, Claudius is C, so he
想做什么就可以做什么。如果改造土地、掏空海底是为了罗马人民的利益，那他就会这么做。所以他继续前行。此外，他非常热衷于引水渠。他修建了两条巨大的引水渠，其中一条“克劳狄乌斯引水渠”可能是罗马所有引水渠中最宏伟的一座。关于它们，最迷人的是，它们和克劳狄乌斯一样，既非常现代又非常古老。所以它们是尖端的工程，但它们却披着传统引水渠的外衣。我认为这是对克劳狄乌斯的精髓的一个绝妙总结：效率、现代性，但却将其包装成古老的样子。我的意思是，这也是
can do what he likes. And if it serves the good of the Roman people to remold the land, to gouge out the bottom of the sea, then that's what he's going to do. And so he goes ahead. He also, he's a great man for an aqueduct. He builds two enormous aqueducts, and one of them, the aqua Claudia, is probably the greatest of all Rome's aqueducts. And what's fascinating about them is that they, like Claudius, are simultaneously very modern and very ancient. So they're kind of cutting edge engineering, but they have the cladding of a kind of old school aqueduct. And I think that's a beautiful summation of what Claudius is about. Efficiency, modernity, but dress it up to look old. I mean, that's basically
我基本上想要的。我必须说，我完全赞成这一点。这些被同时代的人认为是惊人的成就。因此，老普林尼写道，它们是世上无与伦比的奇迹。因此，这显然再次大大增加了克劳狄乌斯的声誉，使他在那些指望凯撒让他们有水喝、有饭吃的人民中变得非常非常受欢迎。这也广受欢迎，因为它为他们提供了工作。因此，干活的不是奴隶，而是广大民众，这是一种凯恩斯主义的计划。是的，把钱注入经济。非常好。因此，另一件事是，克劳狄乌斯虽然有点老派，但他不像提比略那样是一个阴沉的扫兴者，
what I'd like as well. I have to say I'd be all in favour of that. And these are recognised by contemporaries as being astonishing achievements. So Pliny the Elder, he writes that they are wonders without rival in the world. And so obviously this re-downs again greatly to Claudius' credit, makes him very, very popular with the people who look to Caesar to keep them watered, to keep them fed. And it's also popular because it gives them jobs. So it's not slaves who are doing the work. It's the mass of the people and it's kind of Keynesian scheme. Yeah, putting money into the economy. Very good. So the other thing is that Claudius is not, although he's quite old school, he's not like a Tiberius kind of dur killjoy who
对民众的快乐嗤之以鼻。所以你说克劳狄乌斯会喜欢一章关于斯诺克的书。他会喜欢在烟雾缭绕的斯诺克大厅里度过一个夜晚。他绝对会的。是的，他绝对会。正如我所说，他写过一本关于赌博的书，这在当时被认为是一种非常掉价的消遣。他享受着大众的快乐。事实上，他对角斗士格斗如此热衷，以至于苏埃托尼乌斯写道，他对处决有着令人震惊的痴迷——在露天剧场的某场表演日中，高潮将是角斗士，在此之前是猛兽，而在那之前则是处决。而处决这种环节，你知道的，你必须是一个狂热的粉丝才会去看。
sneers at the pleasures of the populace. So you said Claudius would like a chapter on snooker. He'd enjoy a night out at a smoke-filled snooker hall. He absolutely would. Yes, he absolutely would. So as I said, he writes a book on gambling, which is seen as being a very de classe occupation. He enjoys the pleasures of the masses. And in fact, he's so keen on gladiatorial combat that Suetonius writes that he is shockingly obsessed by executions, which in a kind of a day of spectacles in an amphitheatre, the climax would be gladiators, then before that you'd have the wild beasts, and before that you would have the Executions. And the Executions is kind of, you know, you've got to be an obsessive fan to go and watch
而克劳狄乌斯就是那种，你知道的，他确实喜欢去看。所以这就像去看一场著名的乐队演出，然后去看暖场表演。暖场表演。就像去看奥运会，然后去看一些你毫无兴趣的糟糕比赛。对，没错。毫不奇怪，他举办的许多演出都非常非常著名。事实上，其中一场演出催生了罗马历史乃至全部历史中最著名的名言之一。他试图排干罗马上方乡村的一个湖泊。为了标志这个项目的最终完成，在开放排干该湖泊的运河之前，他让人在那里举办了一场宏大的海战。所有被召集到船上进行这场演出的角斗士们转向克劳狄乌斯，此时的他看起来非常光彩照人。
them. And Claudius is a kind of, you know, he does like to go and watch them. So it's like going to see a famous band or something and going to see the warm up act. The warm up act. So going to the Olympics and going to watch like some terrible sport that you've no interest in. Yeah, exactly. It's unsurprising that a lot of the shows that he puts on are very, very famous. And in fact, one of them gives rise to perhaps one of the most famous sayings from the whole of Roman history. He's trying to drain this lake in the countryside above Rome. And to mark the final completion of this project before the canal is open that will drain the
你知道，他坐着，看起来气势非凡，他们说：“凯撒万岁，我们这些即将死去的人向你致敬。”这句话就是这么来的。这个短语就是由此而来的。尽管，我的意思是，这非常非常的克劳狄乌斯，
lake, he has a great sea battle staged there. And all the gladiators who've been assembled onto the boats to stage this turn to Claudius, where he's looking very kind of splendid. You know, he sat down looking tremendously imperious and they say, hail Caesar, we who are about to die salute you. And that's where this is from. That is where that phrase has come from. Although it's, I mean, it's very, very Claudius that
接着他把事情彻底搞砸了。当他们说“我们即将死去的人向你致敬”时，他回答：“或者不，因为，你知道的，也许他们中的一些人，不会死。”我的意思是，这是一种非常大学高级知识分子、非常尖刻的幽默：“或者不”。因此，所有的角斗士听到他这么说，就想，哦，太棒了，他赦免了我们。我们不用战斗了。于是他们放下武器，拒绝战斗。克劳狄乌斯对此愤怒至极，以至于他从宝座上站起来，匆忙走下来对他们大喊大叫，叫他们动作快点。当然，当他这么做时，他一瘸一拐地走着，威严和光彩的印象就大打折扣了。不过，他确实成功说服了这些家伙——角斗士们——重新拿起武器，于是战斗得以继续。
he then totally messes it up. So when they say we're about to die salute you, he replies or not, because, you know, maybe some of them will, won't die. I mean, it's kind of very Donnish, very waspish humor or not. And so all the gladiators hear him say that and so they think, oh, brilliant, he's pardoning us. We don't have to fight. And so they kind of put down their weapons and refuse to fight. And Claudius is so outraged by this that he gets up out of his throne and hurries down to yell at them and tell them to get a move on. And of course, when he does that, he hobbles and limps and the impression of majesty and splendor is compromised. However, he does manage to persuade the guys to the gladiators to pick up their weapons and so the fight goes ahead.
这对群众来说是个好消息。对群众来说是个好消息。绝对的。对角斗士来说可能就没那么好了。现在，这里当然有一个问题，那就是这非常昂贵。再加上克劳狄乌斯的前任卡利古拉也极其热衷于把钱挥霍在穷奢极欲的活动上，所以国库相当空虚，但克劳狄乌斯非常积极主动。同样，我认为他显然仔细考虑过他要做什么。他希望将凯撒宫廷的行政管理建立在尽可能坚实的基础上，
That's good news for the crowd. Good news for the crowd. Absolutely. Maybe less good news for the gladiators. Now, there is of course a problem with this, which is that it's very expensive. And that is compounded by the fact that Claudius' predecessor, Caligula, had also been very keen on lavishing money on extravaganzas. So the treasury is pretty bare, but Claudius is very proactive. And again, I think he's clearly thought about what he's going to do. And he wants to set the administration of the household of Caesar on as firm a footing as he can,
因为他认识到，这种行政管理实际上也是整个帝国的行政管理。因此，在克劳狄乌斯之前，凯撒需要钱的事实——因为他拥有的资金基本上是维持帝国运转的收入——一直被掩盖着，或者至少没有得到适当的承认。但克劳狄乌斯，也许是因为他掌权时的环境，他更像是一个通过政变掌权的军事强人，而不是某种世袭君主，他对于需要使自己的行政管理尽可能精简和高效这一点毫不隐瞒。因此，为此他求助的人，正是任何需要专家的富有罗马人都会求助的人。这些人就是奴隶或解放自由人。因为作为凯撒，他可以挑选最有能力、最聪明的人，
because he recognizes that that administration is also effectively the administration of the entire empire. So until Claudius, the fact that Caesar needs money, because the money that he has is basically the income that keeps the empire running, had been disguised, or at least hadn't properly been acknowledged. But Claudius, perhaps because of the circumstances in which he's come to power, he's more like a military strongman who's come to power in a coup than a kind of hereditary monarch. He's kind of unabashed about the need to make his administration as streamlined and efficient as possible. And so the people he turns to for that are the people that any wealthy Roman
你知道的，比如在金融等各个领域有特定专长的希腊人，因此这些解放自由人基本上被克劳狄乌斯委以管理帝国的重任，事实证明他们在管理方面非常非常有效。所以这些人就像，任何读过《我，克劳狄乌斯》或者还记得纳尔西斯（Narcissus）和帕拉斯（Pallas）等人的人一样，他们想必非常聪明且能干，但我猜他们一定招致了很多嫉妒和仇恨。当然，因为元老院里的每个人都极其怨恨。而且
who needs specialists would turn to. And these are people who are slaves or freedmen. Because as Caesar, he has the pick of the ablest, smartest people, you know, Greeks with particular specialisms in various fields of finance or whatever, and so these freed men are basically entrusted by Claudius with the running of the Empire and they proved to be very, very effective at it. So these are the people like anyone who's read I, Claudius or remember Narcissus and Pallas and people like that who presumably they're very bright and they're very good, but I would guess they must attract a lot of haters. Of course, because everyone in the Senate is massively resentful. And
这也迎合了人们对克劳狄乌斯作为傻瓜老头的刻板印象——他轻易被那些本应被牢牢踩在脚下的人操纵和控制，而奴隶和解放自由人正是这种人的典型代表。因此，正如他受制于这些人一样——也就是那些解放自由人、受宠者——他扮演的不是一个元首（princeps）的角色，而是一个随处分发官职和军事指挥权、赦免和惩罚人们的马屁精，对自己在多大程度上沦为这个或那个受宠者利益的玩物浑然不觉。所以这是克劳狄乌斯形象中至关重要的一部分，即他是个白痴，本质上智力低下，已经成了他身边宠臣的玩物。现在我们知道这不是真的，因为在埃及我们发现——当我说我们时，指的是学者、考古学家——
of course it also plays into the stereotype of Claudius as a foolish old man who is easily manipulated and dominated by people who properly should be kept firmly under thumb of whom slaves and freedmen would be the paradigm. So under the thumb as he was of these men, so that's the freedmen, the favorites, he played the part not of a princeps but of a flunky dispensing magistracies here and military commands there, pardoning and punishing people, largely oblivious to how much he was the creature of this or that favorites interests. So this is a crucial part of the image of Claudius that he's an idiot who essentially is so feeble minded that he's become the plaything of his favorites. Now we know that's not true because in Egypt we found, when I say we, I mean scholars, archaeologists
发现了文献证据，证明克劳狄乌斯对帝国的行政管理给予了密切关注，并且他与罗马世界各地省份的人们的通信表现出明显的智慧。他是一个非常聪明、能干的人。事实上，他有所有这些解放自由人为他服务，这并不是他老迈或痴呆的证据，而是他敏锐地驾驭创新能力的证明。但让他的同代人和后人认为克劳狄乌斯智力低下的部分原因在于，人们有一种感觉：他不只是受制于解放自由人，甚至更糟糕的是受制于女人，
have found documentary evidence for the close attention that Claudius plays to the administration of his empire and the kind of the evident intelligence with which he corresponds to people in provinces across the span of the Roman world. He's a very smart, able guy. And actually the fact he has all these freedmen serving him, this isn't evidence of his senility or imbecility. It's evidence of his astute ability to marshal innovation. But part of what makes his contemporaries and posterity assume that Claudius is feeble-minded is that there's a sense that he's under the thumb not just of freed men but also even worse of women
特别是接连不断的新娘们，其中最声名狼藉的也许是一个名叫梅萨利娜（Messalina）的女人。我本来就希望我们能聊到梅萨利娜。所以梅萨利娜是，他基本上是可以随便挑的，对吧？他挑了一个非常年轻、美丽而且至关重要、血统非常高贵的妻子。我认为高贵血统才是最重要的。我认为美貌和年轻只是，你知道的，这些都是额外的好处。她，也就是威廉·巴伦（Will Barron），是奥古斯都的曾孙女，对吧？所以她帮助他宣称：我是最伟大皇帝、第一位皇帝的继承人。威廉·巴伦。而这正是她发挥的关键作用。这赋予了她某种程度的独立权力。因为克劳狄乌斯知道，其他人也知道，娶了梅萨利娜——
and particularly of a succession of wives of whom perhaps the most notorious is a woman called Messalina. Now I was hoping we'd get on to Messalina. So Messalina is, he basically has his pick I guess, does he? And he picks a very young, beautiful and crucially very blue-blooded white. I think it's the blue-blooded that matters. I think the beauty and youth is a, you know, these are perks. Will Barron She's the great-grandniece of Augustus, right? So she helps him to sort of say, I'm the heir to the greatest emperor, the first emperor. Will Barron And that is a crucial role that she plays. And it gives her a certain degree of independent power. Because Claudius knows, and everyone else knows, that being married to Messalina, who
奥古斯都的曾孙女——这是对他的地位和威望的至关重要的巩固。而她的重要性和她的某种行动独立性，在公元 41 年她给他生下了一个至关重要的男性继承人之后得到了进一步加强。所以他现在有了一个儿子，可以继承这个，你知道的，他在凯撒家族中的角色。有着显赫的名字。对的。两年后，克劳狄乌斯主持了征服英国的战役。于是这个小男孩被赐名为不列颠尼库斯（Britannicus），梅萨利娜在这其中的角色，你知道的，至关重要。因此她基本上让自己变得不可或缺，不仅对克劳狄乌斯政权在当前的地位至关重要，对其未来的前景也至关重要。基本上，这就是它的延续。
is the great-grandniece of Augustus, this is a crucial buttressing of his status and prestige. And her significance and her kind of independence of operation is enhanced by the fact that in AD 41, she gives him crucially a male heir. So he now has a son who can inherit this, you know, his role in the House of Caesar. With a great name. Right. So two years later, Claudius presides over the conquest of Britain. And so this little boy gets given the name of Britannicus and Messalina's role in this, you know, crucial. And so she has basically made herself fundamental, not just to the status of Claudius's regime as it exists
因此，毫不奇怪她在雕像中被描绘成一个稳重、可敬的罗马主妇的典范。她被赞誉为罗马妇女的绝对典范。但是多米尼克，亲爱的听众们，问题来了：她到底是罗马妇女的典范，还是一个声名狼藉的荡妇？好吧，如果你看过或者读过《我，克劳狄乌斯》，你会记得，这可以说是罗马历史上甚至全部历史上最大的丑闻之一。当时克劳狄乌斯，你会记得，这可以说是罗马历史上甚至全部历史上最大的丑闻之一。当时克劳狄乌斯，他正在奥斯蒂亚，对吧？他
in the present, but its prospects in the future. Basically, it's kind of its perpetuation. And so it's unsurprising that she is portrayed in statues as the very model of a sober, respectable Roman matron. And she's praised as the absolute model of Roman womanhood. But Dominic, dear listeners, here's the question. Is she the model of Roman womanhood or is she an outrageous strumpet? Well, if you've seen or indeed read I, Claudius, you will remember that there is, I mean, it's one of the great scandals, not just in Roman history, but all history. When Claudius, you will remember that there is, I mean, it's one of the great scandals, not just in Roman history, but all history. When Claudius, he's at Ostia, isn't he? He's
正在参观那个我向听众推荐的宏伟遗址。如果奥斯蒂亚旅游局想取得联系，我非常乐意听到他们的消息。所以他正在参观奥斯蒂亚，他的一位情妇走过来对他说，梅萨利娜在你的背后胡作非为，而且不仅仅是胡作非为。她走过来对他说，梅萨利娜在你的背后胡作非为，不仅如此，她还搞出了各种花样，汤姆。是的，好吧，她和这个非常英俊、年轻且极具野心的年轻元老有染。故事是说他们在密谋取代克劳狄乌斯的皇帝地位。事实上，梅萨利娜已经嫁给了这家伙，而她是奥古斯都的曾孙女，
looking around that splendid site that I was recommending to the listeners. And if the Ostia tourist board want to get in touch, I'd be very keen to hear from them. So he's looking around Ostia and somebody, a concubine of his, comes up to him and says, Messalino is carrying on behind your back and not just carrying on. She comes up to him and says, Messalina is carrying on behind your back and not just carrying on, she's up to all sorts, Tom. Yeah, well, she's having an affair with this very good looking young senator who's also very ambitious. And the story is that they're conspiring to replace Claudius's emperor. And in fact, that Messalina has married this guy and she's the great grand niece of Augustus
并且是不列颠尼库斯的母亲。所以如果这是真的，这可能对克劳狄乌斯来说是非常非常危险的。他警惕的程度表现在他飞速赶回罗马，他没有去帕拉蒂尼山，而是去了近卫军军营，因为他必须，很显然他很担心，你知道的，他需要确保那里是安全的，因为只有那里是安全的，他才能采取措施应对这个威胁。他的担忧一定在于，你知道的，梅萨利娜和她的玩具男孩可能已经收买或煽动了近卫军。我的意思是，实际情况是没有，这或许表明这个故事被稍微夸大了，但我们一会儿会谈到这一点。无论如何，克劳狄乌斯有能力派遣近卫军出去镇压这场政变，他们也确实这么做了。所以，嗯，所有各种阴谋分子
and she's the mother of Britannicus. So this is potentially, you know, if it's true, very, very dangerous for Claudius. And the measure of his alarm is that he goes speeding back to Rome and he doesn't go to the Palatine, but he goes to the Praetorian camp because he's got to, clearly he's worried, you know, he needs to make sure that that's secure because only if that's secure can he then take measures to deal with this threat. And his worry must have been that, you know, Messalina and her toy boy have might've suborned the Praetorians. I mean, in the event they haven't, which perhaps suggests that the story has been slightly overblown, but we'll come to that in a minute. But anyway, Claudius is in a position to send the praetorians out and suppress the coup, which they do. So, um, all the various conspirators
都被逮捕并处决了。梅萨利娜已经不见了。原来她去找，去寻找她的母亲，这在，你知道的，在她经历危机时刻的时候，她想要妈妈，她们被关在罗马所有贵族都有的那些美丽花园之一里。她在那里被逼入绝境，被近卫军刺穿并扔在她母亲的脚下。这就是梅萨利娜的结局。所以问题是，这到底是怎么回事？现在，我认为从同时代的资料中可以明显看出，梅萨利娜是权力政治中一个非常熟练的玩家，她在除掉潜在竞争对手或任何似乎威胁到她地位的人时非常冷酷无情，我的意思是，也许她真的对不起克劳狄乌斯，这
are arrested and executed. Messalina has vanished. It turns out that she's gone to, uh, find, to find her mother, which is, you know, in her moment of crisis, she wants mummy and they are kind of closeted together in one of their kind of beautiful gardens that all the aristocracy in Rome have. And she's cornered there run through by the Praetorians and dumped at the feet of her mother. And that is the end of Messalina. And so the question is, well, what is going on here? Now, I think it's evident from contemporaneous sources that Meselina is a very proficient player in power politics, that she's very ruthless in getting rid of potential rivals or anyone who seems to threaten her mean, maybe she's been cheating on Claudius, can't
无法确定。但你知道，她真的在阴谋反对他吗？是的，也许人们，曾经发生过一点我们看不到的内部权力斗争，也许官僚们、解放自由人已经，你知道的，背叛了她。这可能吗？完全可能。那个去奥斯蒂亚见克劳狄乌斯的情妇，她是受到克劳狄乌斯手下最强大的解放自由人之一的唆使的，而这些人在整个事件的背景中一直潜伏着。所以，我认为梅萨利娜在一场由她的支持者与权力过大的解放自由人之间的派系斗争中被消灭，
be sure. But you know, was she really conspiring against him? Yeah, maybe people have, there's been a bit of an internal power struggle we don't, that we can't really glimpse and that maybe the bureaucrats, the freed men have, you know, turned against her. Is that possible? Definitely. That concubine who goes to see Claudius at Ostia, she is prompted by one of Claudius's most powerful freedmen and they are lurking in the background of this whole episode. So it is, I think, likelier that Messalina is destroyed in a kind of faction fight between her supporters and kind of over mighty freedmen
要比她真的在搞各种乱七八糟的性丑闻更有可能。所以就像鲍里斯·约翰逊（Boris Johnson）的最后日子一样，当时他的妻子凯莉（Carrie）和他的一些助手之间存在竞争性的简报，记得吗？我的意思是，那种……我的意思是，从罗马历史的角度来看，这是一个关键时刻，你知道的，这是一件大事。显然有各种各样的政治利益在博弈，但我们只是不知道真相是什么。这指向了一种方式：几个世纪以来一直元老院议事大厅里进行的权力争夺，现在正在帕拉蒂尼山的侧室、
than that she really was kind of getting up to kind of all kinds of sexual shenanigans. So like the last days of Boris Johnson, where there was rival briefing between his wife Carrie and some of his aides, remember? I mean, that kind of... I mean, I think from the point of view of Roman history, this is a key moment because, you know, this is a huge event. There are clearly all kinds of political interests at stake, but we just don't know what the truth is. And it points to the way in which rivalries that for centuries and centuries have been played out on the floor of the Senate house are now being conducted in side rooms
通道和卧室里进行。这意味着确定性是不可能的。而缺乏确定性反过来又孕育了丑闻般的流言蜚语。这就是为什么会有这些极其耸人听闻的故事。同样，《我，克劳狄乌斯》对这些故事进行了极大的渲染，说她曾与罗马顶级的名妓进行过，你自己在笔记中将其描述为一个全天的性爱马拉松。是的。所以可以说是罗马最有经验、最老练的妓女，她们正面对决，据说。对的。而梅萨利娜赢了。这显然没有发生。
and passageways and bedrooms in the Palatine. And it means that certainty is impossible. And the lack of certainty in turn breeds scandalous gossip. And that's what explains these incredibly lurid stories. Again, I, Claudius has great fun with these that she has been, you know, you describe it in your notes as an all day sexathon with Rome's top courtesan. Yes. So Rome's most experienced and seasoned whore and they go head to head, it is said as it were. Right. And Messalina wins. And that obviously didn't happen. No, it obviously didn't happen. And also what obviously didn't happen is what Juvenal claims in his poems, he's a satirist writing kind of maybe half a century or so
不，这显然没有发生。同样显然没有发生的，还有尤维纳利斯（Juvenal）在他的诗中所宣称的——他是一位讽刺作家，写作时间大约在梅萨利娜死后半个世纪左右。他将她描述为一种怀旧做派，乔装打扮去一个低档妓院工作。尤维纳利斯说他，你知道的，她给乳头镀金，在头发上戴着金发假发，躺在这个肮脏不堪的房间里，平民们走进来，对她为所欲为。这显然不是真的，但它暗示了帕拉蒂尼山的这些派系斗争现在能够激起的窥淫癖和猎奇心理。当然，这对梅萨利娜的身后名声非常糟糕，但对克劳狄乌斯的身后名声也同样糟糕。事实上，当他还活着时，他的名声也很糟糕，因为这给他留下了一个双重问题。这让他看起来软弱、被戴绿帽子、受蒙蔽，这就迎合了所有关于他作为解放自由人的玩物的流言蜚语。
after Messalina's death. And he describes her as kind of nostalgia de la boo, uh, going off and working incognita in a low rent brothel. And juvenile says that he, you know, she gilds her nipples and, uh, wears a blonde wig over her hair and kind of lies on this dirty, dirty room where plebeians come and have their way with her. And this is clearly not true, but it suggests the kind of titillation that these faction fights in the Palatine are now capable of generating. And of course, it's very bad for Messalina's posthumous reputation, but it's also terrible for Claudius' posthumous reputation. And in fact, his reputation when he's still alive, because it leaves him with a double problem. It leaves him looking kind of weak, cook-holded, deluded, and that plays into all the stories
但这也剥夺了他支撑其政权的关键支柱，因为他不再拥有与奥古斯都血脉的婚姻联系，而且他显然觉得这太重要了，以至于他准备触犯罗马最神圣的一些法律来解决这个问题，因为有一个合适的人选就在手边。有一个女人，你知道的，她不仅是曾孙女，她是奥古斯都的曾孙女。这是卡利古拉幸存的两个姐姐中的一个，大家可能还记得，她们俩曾被她们的兄弟流放到监狱岛，当克劳狄乌斯掌权时，他允许她们返回，并且他与其中一个名叫阿格里皮娜（Agrippina）的女人变得非常亲密，就像她的母亲一样，令人困惑的是，她被历史学家称为小阿格里皮娜（Agrippina the Younger）。她非常漂亮，非常聪明。克劳狄乌斯认为她很棒，但我想，除非他的需求迫在眉睫，否则他是不会通过一项废除叔叔娶侄女禁忌的法律的。
that are being told about him as the plaything of his freedmen. But it's also deprived him of a kind of crucial buttress upholding his regime because he no longer has a marital link to the bloodline of Augustus, And he clearly feels that this is so important that he is prepared to offend some of the most sacred laws of Rome to deal with the problem, because there is a suitable candidate on hand. There is a woman who, you know, she's not just a great granny, she's a great granddaughter of Augustus. And this is one of the two surviving sisters of Caligula, the pair of them people may remember had been exiled to Prison Island by their brother, and when Claudius came to power he'd allowed them to return, and he'd
他说，不，这绝对是合法的。他继续前行，迎娶了阿格里皮娜。苏埃托尼乌斯说，当他准备迎娶阿格里皮娜、公然违背所有道德时，他在每一次演讲中都不停地将她描述为他的女儿、他的受监护人、在他充满爱意的怀抱中出生并抚养长大的人。所以这非常令人毛骨悚然，但更重要的是，这证明了他的绝望。尽管他已经统治了大约十年，但那种不安全感、那种担心自己不是真正的凯撒、需要一个能让他觉得自己是真正的凯撒的妻子的焦虑依然存在。为了让人们有个概念，他 59 岁，她 34 岁。所以有 25 岁的年龄差距，整整 25 岁。而且她已经有了自己的儿子，比不列颠尼库斯大得多，对吧？
become very close to one of them, a woman called Agrippina, so like her mother, confusingly, so she's called Agrippina the Younger by historians. And she's very beautiful, very smart. Claudia thinks she's great, but I think unless his need had been what it was, he would not have passed a law revoking the taboo against an uncle marrying his niece. And he says, no, this is absolutely legitimate. And he goes niece and he says no this is absolutely legitimate and he goes ahead and he marries Agrippina and Suetonius says as he was getting ready to marry Agrippina in defiance of all morality he kept describing her in every speech he gave as his daughter his ward born and raised
是的，大四五岁，当你 12 岁时——就像阿格里皮娜的儿子那样——我的意思是，这是一个相当大的年龄差距。这是一个名叫卢基乌斯·多米提乌斯·阿赫诺巴尔布斯（Lucius Domitius Ahenobarbus）的年轻男孩，随他父亲的名字。他当然有两个比不列颠尼库斯更有利的优势。其中一个，我们刚刚提到过，他年龄更大，你知道的，当你处于青少年时期时，大四五岁是一个相当大的优势。而另一个优势当然是他是奥古斯都的直系后裔。还有第三个优势，那就是阿格里皮娜极其渴望看到他而不是不列颠尼库斯登上皇位。她向克劳狄乌斯施压，要求收养这个年轻男孩。果不其然，在公元 50 年 2 月 25 日，
in his loving embrace so it's very creepy but more than that it's evidence of his desperation. Still, even though he's now about a decade into his reign, the sense of insecurity, the anxiety that he's not a real Caesar and he needs a wife who will make him feel a real Caesar. Just to give people a sense of it, he is 59, she is 34. So a 25 year, exactly 25 year age gap. And she already has a son of her own who is much older than Britannicus, right? Yeah, four or five years older, which when you're 12, as Agrippina's son is, I mean, that's quite an age gap. And this is a young lad called Lucius Domitius Ahenobarbus after
也就是他与阿格里皮娜结婚后不久，克劳狄乌斯收养了年轻的卢基乌斯·多米提乌斯·阿赫诺巴尔布斯，这个男孩正式成为克劳狄乌斯的长子，作为标志，他有了一个新名字，这个新名字就是尼禄·克劳狄乌斯·凯撒，也就是我们所知的尼禄。是的，所以这不会有好结果。公平地说，对阿格里皮娜而言，她很可能会想，如果我不这么做，总有一天不列颠尼库斯会成为皇帝，他很可能会杀了我儿子，因为我儿子将是一个竞争对手。我想她正是这么想的。我想，即使尼禄这个名字没有投下后来那样的阴影，单单听听这种设定，你知道的，它就具有某种民间故事的特质。
his father. And he of course has two advantages over Britannicus. So one of them, we've just mentioned the fact that he's older and you know, when you're when you're in your teens, being four or five years older is a considerable advantage. And the other thing of course is that he's a direct descendant of Augustus. And there's a third advantage, which is that Agrippina is really, really ambitious to see him rather than Britannicus on the throne. And she presses Claudius to adopt this young lad. And sure enough, on the 25th of February 50, so very shortly after
你可以看到它有点像灰姑娘的故事，糊涂的父亲痴迷于新妻子，被抛弃的孩子，所有这些元素都在那里。果然，在公元 54 年 10 月 13 日，此时克劳狄乌斯掌权刚好不到 14 年，帕拉蒂尼山向罗马人民发布了一个公告。这个公告称克劳狄乌斯已死。不久之后，当时已经 16 岁的尼禄从帕拉蒂尼山走出来，受到近卫军护卫的欢呼，被拥立为凯撒，他被安置在一顶轿子里，就像大约 14 年前克劳狄乌斯那样，被抬了出去。
his marriage to Agrippina, Claudius adopts the young Lucius Domitius Ahenobarbus and the boy formally becomes Claudius' eldest son and as a marker of this he takes on a new name and this new name is Nero Claudius Caesar or as we know him Nero. Yeah, so this isn't going to end well. I mean, to be fair to Agrippina, she might well be thinking if I don't do this, one day Brassanicus will become emperor and he'll probably kill my son because my son will be a rival claimant. I think that's exactly what she thinks. And I think that that even if the name of Nero didn't cast the shadow that it does, I think just listening to that setup, you know, it
克劳狄乌斯与阿格里皮娜结婚后，收养了年轻的卢修斯·多米提乌斯·阿赫诺巴布斯，这个男孩正式成为克劳狄乌斯的长子。作为一个标志，他起了一个新名字，这个新名字就是尼禄·克劳狄乌斯·凯撒，也就是我们所知的尼禄。是的，所以这件事不会有什么好结果。我的意思是，平心而论，阿格里皮娜可能在想，如果我不这么做，总有一天布里塔尼库斯会成为皇帝，他可能会杀了我儿子，因为我会儿子将是一个潜在的竞争对手。我想她就是这么想的。而且我认为，即使尼禄这个名字没有投下现在这样的阴影，仅仅听这个开局，你知道，它
has the quality of a kind of folk tale. You can see it's kind of Cinderella story, the befuddled father obsessing over a new wife, the child who gets abandoned, all these kind of elements are there. Sure enough, on 13th October, 54, so Claudius has been power by this point, just under 14 years, an announcement is released from the Palatine to the Roman people. And this announcement says that Claudius is dead. And shortly afterwards, Nero, who by this point is 16 years old, he comes out from the Palatine, he's hailed by a Praetorian escort as Caesar, he's placed in a litter and as Claudius had been some 14 years previously, he is taken
有一种民间故事的特质。你能看出这有点像灰姑娘的故事，糊涂的父亲痴迷于新妻子，被抛弃的孩子，所有这些元素都在那里。果然，在公元54年10月13日，此时克劳狄乌斯掌权刚刚不到14年，罗马人从帕拉蒂尼宫发布了一则公告。公告称克劳狄乌斯已死。不久之后，当时年仅16岁的尼禄从帕拉蒂尼宫走出来，他在禁卫军的护送下被欢呼为凯撒，被抬进轿子里，就像14年前克劳狄乌斯那样，他被带走了
to the Praetorian camp. So Agrippina and Nero likewise have recognized that this is the key to seizing power of the capital. Within a year, Britannicus is dead, supposedly of a seizure, but of course everyone assumes that Nero has had him poisoned. Agrippina herself dies in 59, she is definitely murdered by Nero, I mean Nero makes no bones about that. And Nero himself of course dies in 68, as we heard in the details of how he died, we heard in the very opening reading of this series and with him dies Augustus's bloodline. That's it. There are no more heirs of Augustus. Let's go back to Claudius for a second. He died in October 54. So that's what four years
来到禁卫军军营。因此阿格里皮娜和尼禄也意识到，这是夺取首都权力的关键。一年之内，布里塔尼库斯就去世了，据说是由于癫痫发作，但当然每个人都认为尼禄派人毒死了他。阿格里皮娜本人于59年去世，她绝对是被尼禄谋杀的，我的意思是尼禄对此毫不掩饰。而尼禄本人当然也在68年去世，正如我们在本系列开篇的朗读中所听到的那样，关于他死去的细节，奥古斯塔斯的血脉也随之断绝。就是这样。奥古斯都再也没有继承人了。让我们回到克劳迪乌斯身上。他于公元54年10月去世。这就是那四年
after he'd adopted Nero as his heir. And it's always thought, isn't it? Thanks largely, probably to Suetonius and also to I. Claudiusius that he was poisoned by Agrippina and Nero with mushrooms. Suetonius says he was poisoned with a dish of mushrooms. Do you think that's true? Well, so I think when Suetonius is the first to report something, that's when you need to be on your guard. That's suspicious.
在他收养尼禄为继承人之后。人们一直这么认为，不是吗？这很大程度上要归功于苏埃托尼乌斯以及《我，克劳迪乌斯》，他被阿格里皮娜和尼禄用蘑菇毒死了。苏埃托尼乌斯说他是用一盘蘑菇毒死的。你认为这是真的吗？嗯，我认为当苏埃托尼乌斯是第一个报道某事的人时，这时候你就需要保持警惕了。这很可疑。
Suetonius is not the first to report that Claudius was murdered by with a dish of poison mushrooms. So Pliny the Elder mentions it. But I mean, having said that, we don't know. I mean, maybe he dies of natural causes. I mean, he'd been sickly all his life. He's had a good innings, you know, he's 63 when he finally pops his clogs. And there's, Jezara Osgood, who's written a brilliant book on Claudius Caesar. In that, he points out that there had been a lot of plague in Rome at the time. He points to evidence from Tacitus of people, large number of high ranking people who died. So that suggests that there's quite a lot of sickness around. And the honest truth is, is that we can't
苏埃托尼乌斯并不是第一个报道克劳迪乌斯是被一盘毒蘑菇谋杀的人。老普林尼也提到过这一点。但是，话虽如此，我们并不清楚。我的他是死于自然原因也说不定。我的他是从小到大身体一直都不好。他活得很久了，你知道的，他最终去世时已经63岁了。而且，杰扎拉·奥斯古德写过一本关于克劳迪乌斯·凯撒的精彩书籍。在书中，他指出当时罗马曾发生过大量瘟疫。他指出了塔西陀关于人们的证据，大量的高官死亡。这表明当时周围有很多疾病。老实说，我们无法
know. And I guess that, I mean, you would say as a historian who has, you know, I mean, think of all the episodes we did on 1968 or Kennedy or whatever. I mean, it's so much material that this is a cause of frustration. But I think it's also, it's, it breeds what to me is part of the fascination of this period and of Suetonius' biographies, which is the way that recorded fact and myth kind of blur into one another. And sometimes you can distinguish the lineaments of history and other times you see the lineaments of mythology. And trying to make sense of that, for for me is what makes this whole story so fascinating. You know, we talked about it, this is the ultimate dynastic story. It's why I, Claudius,
知道。我想，作为一个历史学家，你会说，你知道的，想想我们做过的关于1968年或肯尼迪等所有期节目。我的有这么多的素材，这确实令人沮丧。但我认为这也是，它孕育了我所认为的这段时期和苏埃托尼乌斯传记的魅力所在，也就是历史记载的事实与神话相互交织的方式。有时你可以辨别出历史的轮廓，而有时你又会看到神学的轮廓。试图理解这一点，对我来说正是这个故事如此迷人的原因。你知道的，我们讨论过，这是终极的王朝故事。这就是为什么《我，克劳迪乌斯》
you know, as a novel, but even more as a TV drama kind of lies at the head of all these great dynastic epics that we've had on TV over the past decades. And the fact that Suetonius' account has this kind of mythic folkloric quality, as well as kind of quoting letters and, you know, citing laws and things, I think is a crucial part of that. No, I agree. I agree completely. But actually, where I'd slightly probably disagree with you
你知道的，作为一部小说，甚至更作为一部电视剧，它构成了过去几十年我们在电视上看到的所有这些伟大王朝史诗的开端。苏埃托尼乌斯的叙述具有这种神话般的民间传说色彩，同时又引用书信，你知道的，引用法律等等，我认为这是其中至关重要的一部分。不，我同意。我完全同意。但实际上，我可能稍微不同意你的一点是
is I don't necessarily think this is actually as different from modern history as you would think, because modern history, too, is freighted with all kinds of assumptions, folk myths, urban myths, and actually teasing out what really happened is the impossible goal for any historian of any period. I was just thinking about the, you know, when I was thinking about the death of Claudius and, you know, was he murdered? Was he not? And then of course thinking about that series we did on Kennedy and kind of yearning for the equivalent of a Warren report or something, you know, all the kind of the whole range
我不认为这实际上与你想象的现代历史有那么大不同，因为现代历史同样充斥着各种假设、民间神话、都市传说，而实际上弄清到底发生了什么对于任何时期的任何历史学家来说都是一个不可能实现的目标。我刚刚在想，你知道的，当我想到克劳迪乌斯的死时，你知道的，他是被谋杀了？还是没有？然后自然而然地想到我们制作的关于肯尼迪的那系列节目，并且渴望能有一个相当于沃伦委员会报告之类的东西，你知道的，所有各种各样的
of pieces of evidence that you could bring to bear and thinking how frustrating it is we don't have that. But of course, Kennedy is a myth, isn't he? Right. And also, which wouldn't solve the, you know, wouldn't end the conversation. I mean, because these things don't. So if people want to make up their own minds, what they should do is to buy Tom's new translation of Suetonius' book, The Lives of the Caesars, which is available now from all good bookshops with Penguin Classics. Tom, a great translation, a great series, I have to say. A Tour de Force, I think, is the approved Restless History terminology.
你可以调用的证据，并觉得没有这些是多么令人沮丧。但当然，肯尼迪是一个神话，不是吗？没错。而且，这也无法解决，你知道的，无法结束对话。因为这些事情就是这样。所以如果人们想自己做决定，他们应该做的是购买汤姆对苏埃托尼乌斯著作《恺撒传》的新译本，该书现在可以通过企鹅经典丛书在所有优秀书店买到。汤姆，这是一部伟大的译作，一个伟大的系列，我必须这么说。我认为这是“不安历史”栏目中标准的巅峰之作。
So that was absolutely tremendous. And by the way, the book is brilliant. So people should absolutely go and buy the book. And we will be back next week with something very different, another of history's great monsters, actually, and another story in which it's actually quite difficult to get at, as it were, the truth of what really happened because there are so many different accounts. And that is the story of King Leopold and the Belgian Congo. So we will be telling that story next week. The Heart of Darkness indeed.
所以这绝对是太棒了。顺便说一句，这本书非常精彩。所以人们绝对应该去买这本书。我们下周将带着完全不同的内容回归，历史上另一位伟大的恶魔，实际上，这是另一个故事，在这个故事中，要想探究到底发生了什么的真相其实非常困难，因为有太多不同的说法。这就是利奥波德国王和比属刚果的故事。所以我们将在下周讲述这个故事。确实是黑暗之心。
Okay, on that bombshell, Goodbye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好了，带着这个重磅消息，再见。再见。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。